>> SPEAKER: It removed the
process of drafting policy from
the eyes of the press and from
the atmosphere of policy
politics.  It hid the process
somewhat.
>> SPEAKER: It was secret.
>> SPEAKER: I would call a
benign  secrecy, and I don't
think the history has ever been
written, but if you look at the
15 members of the Carnying
Commission, you see the man, JC
Kellem, who headed the
television stations in Texas.
You see a Texan, you see the
President of the United Auto
Workers.  Why?  Because Johnson
wanted a tremendous lobbying
push, and if the chairman of the
UAW in Detroit was one of the
people who crafted the idea for
the  Corporation of Public
Broadcasting, that meant they
would be behind the bill when it
came to the hill.  So, all of
this was apart of LBJ's
legislative genius, and as I
said earlier, I hope someday, a
historian will delve into these
legislative task forces, because
it seems to  me, one of the
most creative, and really,
praise-worthy, despite the
secrecy, one of the most praise-
worthy things in that history,
and it is all apart of a larger
story.  Um, were it not for the
dark cloud of Vietnam, I think
the LBJ presidency would be
remembered as, um, as the new
deal is remembered, as a
flowering of creativity and
positive legislation on behalf
of the well-being of the
American people.  I see it, I
see the great society chapter,
which really ended at about
1967, after the Congress changed
its composition in 66.  I see
it as the concluding chapter of
the new deal.  Johnson told Bill
Moyers on the plane coming back
from Dallas that he wanted to
do all the things that Franklin
had been unable to do, and so
there was this tremendous, um,
election majority that brought
on the coat-tails into the
Congress a tremendous working
majority, and he used that
majority to pass Medicare, more
than 60 education bills,
including the great, um,
Corporation for Public
Broadcasting bill.  The other
thing, and Newton mentioned it,
was bipartisanship.  The
commission was made-up of
Republicans and Democrats, the
support on  Capitol Hill came
from Republicans and  Democrats.
To this day, if you look at
the trustees of the stations
around the country, when I was
traveling for PBS, I'd speak to
trustees at fundraising dinners
around the country for the
stations, it was the civic arts
and business leadership of every
metropolitan area in the
country, made-up largely of
Republicans, and they could be
counted upon when these periodic
outbursts of insanity occur of
misguided people, they can't
kill, but  wanted to wound
public broadcasting.  These
Republican trustees from all
over the country get on the
phone and say what are you
doing?
>> SPEAKER: They're still doing
it speak.
>> SPEAKER: They are, and we
can count on that.  Senator
Warner from Virginia told me
once that the Congress would
never kill public broadcasting,
because it now is the only way
that a member of Congress can
get on television in his local
community.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: So, I hope that
they are inviting, um, their
members of Congress to appear
frequently, but, um, I went to
the White House after the great
landslide of, um, 64, really, a
sort of gopher for Douglas Cater
, who was in charge of
shepherding the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting into reality
, and our office, in the
basement of the west wing,
really became a sort of workshop
where the  members of the
Carnegie Commission, first, John
Gardener of the Carnegie
Commission, and then Ellen
Pifer, I would like to claim
some creative role in this, but
I really was, you know, I came
to the White House, having been
a green reporter for the
Washington Post, so I was a kind
of gopher, but I was also a
watcher, and what I watched was
visionary people, um, doing
amazing things, and it had a
shaping influence, it was a
great graduate school of my
life, and my boss hated to write
speeches, and because I had
been a newspaper reporter, he
would shove all the speech-
writing off to me, and, um, when
we passed the legislation and
Johnson had to make a speech,
signing the bill, I was given
the task of writing the speech,
and about 48 hours before the
speech was locked up and sent
into what was called the
President's night reading, John
Gardener, by now, the secretary,
called, and he said we need to
extend the vision of this speech
beyond  broadcasting and talk
about all public media, and he
didn't even know what that meant
at the time, but he suggested
language, and I want to quote a
little bit of it, because it is
so visionary and so symbolic of
all that was going on in that
fertile period of our time.
Right in the middle of the
speech, signing the bill,
Johnson said these words, "I
want to create a great network
for knowledge.  Not just a
broadcast system, but one that
employs every means of sending
and storing information.  Think
of the lives that this could
change; the student in a small
college could tap the resources
of a great university; the
country doctor could get help
from a distant laboratory or
teaching hospital; a scholar in
Atlanta might draw instantly on
a library in New York."  Now,
all this is 30 years before the
Internet, but suddenly, um, the
chrysalis is beginning to form,
and the creative vision of a
network for knowledge, the
stations of NPR and PBS had not
always been receptive, I'm sorry
to say, to new technology, and
a station manager once said to
me, when we were trying to
create PBS.org, um, every hour
that a viewer spends looking at
a computer screen is an hour
that he is not watching my
station.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And, um, so,
there's been a certain
hostility, but we know that
right there in the womb, um,
when the bill was signed, the
President of the United States
was envisioning something called
networks for knowledge.  May
that, um, increase, may it grow,
may the commitment of all
public broadcasters to public
media, um, flourish in the
future, but, um, it was great
fun to be in on the beginning,
though I can't claim anything
other than a gopher's role, but
what a great thing we did.  It
is now embedded in the culture,
it is, um, apart of American
life in the way that Medicare,
um, other great achievements of
that time are sewn into the
fabric of American life, and
heroes of that movement are in
this room.  May their tribe
increase.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: So, Nick,
what was the role of the FCC in
all of this?
>> SPEAKER: Well, I would like
to go back a little further.
>> SPEAKER: Okay.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Since I believe Mr.
Martin and I are amongst
the more, um, age of
experience, you know, and, so --
>> SPEAKER: The wise men.
>> SPEAKER: What?
>> SPEAKER: Well, not
necessarily, as we often see.
>> SPEAKER: I'm just trying to
help.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: But to go back to
the 18th century, um, because --
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: There are other
Presidents involved in this
beside Lyndon Johnson, with
regard to whom I might add an
anecdote that he brought me in
in February of 64, and shortly
thereafter, a memo went out to
all presidential appointees, you
may recall this, saying I want
you to tell me what you think
would be in the best interest of
our nation with the area for
which you have responsibility,
and in my case, at that time, it
was ports and ship-building and
shipping.  He made me maritime
administrator, just exactly what
you would think, a boy from
Iowa.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: The coast of Iowa.
>> SPEAKER: With shipping
experience limited to, um,
operating a canoe on the Iowa
River, but not very
successfully, something that,
thankfully, the commerce
committee found fully adequate
to justify the appointment, but,
um, I think that's another
thing to say about Lyndon
Johnson, that compared with, um,
other Presidents, perhaps, who
will go unnamed, that there
would actually be that focus on
what's in the best national
interest, but I want to go back
to, um, Madison, who I just
learned today is referred to by
those who work at the library of
Congress as Jimmy Madison.
>> SPEAKER: Yes, he was Jemmy.
>> SPEAKER: Is that right? Was
it James Madison?
>> SPEAKER: Jemmy.
>> SPEAKER: I'll be darned.
Did your father tell you that?
>> SPEAKER: No, I write history
books.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: They would be so
proud of you now and everything
you've done.  I'm serious
.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Well, anyhow, I
want to go back to, um, Jemmy
Madison, however you spell his
name, and there's an inscription
, as you came into this
building, you may have noticed,
and I'm going to link this up
with Thomas Jefferson, and then
ultimately with, um, public
broadcasting and try to do it in
5 minutes or less, if that's
all right.
>> SPEAKER: That's all right.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, less will be
better.  Less is more.  Yeah.
Um, and it contains this line,
"a people who mean to be their
own governors must arm them
selves with the power which
knowledge gives."  That's
Madison's  quote.  Jefferson,
and many of you may know this,
but when writing his own epitaph
, chose to be remembered as the
father of the University of
Virginia, and made no mention of
the fact that he'd been
President of the United States
.  Now, this is very significant
, I think, because what these
folks were doing was recognizing
and establishing and making
efforts to maintain fundamental
pillars of democracy, many of
which have always been and
continue to be today, um, under
attack.  One, obviously, is
extending the franchise from
originally white, male,
landowners over 21, um, to where
now, we even let women vote.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Took awhile.
>> SPEAKER: It did take a long
while, um, and 18-year-olds, but
then the addition of free
public education, a fundamental
element and pillar of democracy,
and then the idea of
independent media, protected by
the First Amendment
, for Jefferson also said,
famously, as you all know, "were
it left to me to decide whether
we should have a government
without newspapers or newspapers
without a government, I should
not hesitate a moment to prefer
the latter."  And then went on
in the next sentence to say,"
but I should mean that every
person should receive those
papers and be capable of reading
them."  Again, tying it to
education.  Subsequently, we
added the idea of free public
libraries, where every American
could have access to the
resources of kings, and indeed,
this library was contributed to
by Jefferson in 1815, as you
probably know
.  Something that is often not
thought about in this context,
but related to John Gardener, he
wrote two  paperback books, one
called Excellence, one called
Self-Renewal, which I think are
always worth re-reading, at
least every 20 or 30  years, um,
because the other thing we did
was to establish reduced rates
for sending newspapers and
books and magazines through the
postal system, subsidizing what
was, at that time, the
communications network of the
19th century, was the Post
Office, and then we added
telegraph and telephones and so
on, but that was how it began,
and as all of you know, the
early, um, time of radio, and I
want to tell just one story
about Iowa City, and then I'm
done, is that okay?  Okay.  Um,
the early days of radio involved
, um,
numerous, 72, in the very early
days, educational institutions
that did not only the
technological work of creating
this box in which little people
lived and could talk, but also,
the programming, and the focus
on the use of this as an
instrument of education.  In
Iowa City, Iowa, a city
designated by the United Nations
as one of three global cities
of literature, um, was created
the first educational radio
station west of the Mississippi.
That was in 1911.   So, this
goes back before 1967, for those
who are younger among us here
today.  Um, in 1971, WSUI became
a charter member of NPR, one
of, um, the early few, and one
of the 90 stations to carry the
inaugural broadcast of, um, Bill
's  All Things Considered.  In
1916, it began transmitting
educational content, ultimately
including my father's lectures
in the 19 40s.  By the late 19
20s, remember this, 19 20s, they
had educational television, um,
broadcasting television images
of, um, classroom content, a
station that would ultimately be
one of the founding stations
creating Iowa public television,
and thus
ends the reading for  today.
(Laughing.)
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Well, Bill, that
nicely gets us to you.  Um, the
fact is, you know, we heard all
about educational TV, and even
though radio came before, um, it
was something of an
afterthought in terms of public
broadcasting, and you were the
person who changed that.
>> SPEAKER: It was actually
scotch-taped at the last minute
on to the legislation.
>> SPEAKER: And radio.
>> SPEAKER: It's like the Civil
Rights  Law putting and sex in
and changing women's lives
forever, but, um--
>> SPEAKER: If I can note, I
took the position at that time
that we ought to forget about
television and start with radio.
You got literally ten times
more for your dollar with radio
than with television.
>> SPEAKER: That's still true.
>> SPEAKER: That's right.
Build a really strong national
political base in support of
public radio that would then
clamor
and demand of Congress public
television, but to start with
public television and underfund
it, I didn't think was the right
political move.  Bill.
(Laughing.)
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Because many of you
are historians, and we've had,
um, history of universities, I'd
like to just go back.  I was, a
couple weeks ago, I was out in
Madison, Wisconsin, celebrating
the hundredth anniversary of the
oldest station, the oldest
educational station, continuous
broadcasting.
>> SPEAKER: Well, but east of
the Mississippi.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: That's right. We
could  arm-wrestle about this.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Um, and, um,
tracing this back to the
universities, because I think
this is very, a good point,
about 11 years before radio was
invented, um, the university
President said I was the
beneficence of the university to
be at every home in the state,
and it became the motto of the
so-called Wisconsin Idea, the
boundaries of the cappests are
the boundaries of the state.
So, that was the idea of
extending those resources, and
at that time, the very first
broadcast, east of the
Mississippi, by an educational
station was information to
farmers; weather information, 61
percent were, 61 percent
literacy rate at that time in
Wisconsin.  Um, as just a side
bar, um, she mentioned I have an
organization developing radio
partners, and we're working in
Zambia to improve the weather
and farming information, where
the literacy rate is 61 percent.
>> SPEAKER: Back in the
beginning.
>> SPEAKER: So, radio continues
to be used this way.  So
anyway, that idea continued, so
the beginnings really were there
, and I started my career in
public radio as an engineer in
1952, working my way through the
University of Wisconsin, so,
um, that's where  I, my roots
are there, and there was, um, a
center for innovation and audio
innovation and so on there,
producing, um, radio plays
.  Anyway, it was that
experience that informed  me.
Um, I left there and was in
Buffalo and developed a
storefront center broadcast
facility in the heart of the
Black Community, where, um, 27
hours a week came from that
source, so I was, at that time,
giving voice, or helping give
voice to folks that had no,
there were no people of color,
really, in media at that time.
Um, and we had discussions about
race on air; what is it like
to be an African American in
our society.
>> SPEAKER: What year are we in
now?
>> SPEAKER: We're in 1963 and
64, and, um, I did a series on
the confederacy, nation within a
nation.  Anyway, so, when I was
tasked, as a member of the
founding board, to write the
mission statement, um, I felt
very strongly about radio.  Our
first meeting, I was on the
radio advisory committee, and
John macey said to us, well, you
know, of course, television has
to go first.  Of course,
television always goes first,
and, um, I was, um, really
always frustrated by this, of
course, because, um, so, I
started a program in  Buffalo
called This Is Radio.  This is
radio, damn it, pay attention.
I'm still saying the same thing
in development.  Anyway, so, the
task was to try to, for me, um,
differentiate it from the
educational radio, from
commercial radio, from PBS, to
capitalize the unique strengths
of radio as a sound medium,
getting out of the studio,
telling stories, and, um, to be
somewhat aspirational, but also
practical.  So, that was what I
was trying to do when I wrote,
um, the mission statement.  If
you don't mind, I'll just read a
few paragraphs of that.
National public radio will serve
the  individual.  It will
promote personal growth.  It
will regard individual
differences with respect and joy
rather than hate.  It will
celebrate the human experiences
infinitely varied rather than
vackious bunow.  It will
encourage a sense of active,
constructive participation
rather than apathetic
helplessness.  The total service
should be trustworthy, enhance
intellectual development, expand
knowledge, deepen oral esthetic
enjoyment, increase the
pleasure of living in a
pluralistic society, and result
in a service to listeners which
makes them more responsive,
informed human beings, and
intelligent, responsible
citizens of their communities
and the world.  And then in the
first description of what became
All Things Considered, I said
that it would not substitute
superficial  blandness for
genuine diversity of regions,
values and cultural and ethnic
minorities, which comprised
American society.  It would
speak with many voices and many
dialects.  The editorial
attitude would be that of
inquiry, curiosity, concern for
the quality of life, critical,
problem-solving, and life-loving
.  The listener should come to
rely upon it as a source of
information of consequence, that
having listened has made a
difference in their attitude
toward their environment and
themselves.  And then the
concluding paragraph for now,
philosophically, time is
measured by the intensity of
experience.  Waiting for a bus
and walking through an art
gallery may occupy the same
duration of time, but not the
same time experience.  Listeners
should feel that the time spent
with NPR was among their most
rewarding in media contact.
National public radio will not
regard its audience as a market,
or in terms of its disposable
income, but as curious, complex
individuals who are looking for
some understanding, meaning, and
joy in the human experience.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Well, so now you
have a good sense of how it all
began, and since these gentlemen
have been broadcasters, we're
finishing right on time, at 3:00
o'clock, in time for the next
panel.  Thank you, gentlemen,
very,
very much.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you. Thank
you all very much.  That was
wonderful.  Um, as we setup for
the next panelists, would the
next set of panelists please
come on the stage?  We're going
to show a clip.  The next panel
is on news and public affairs
and talk shows, and while the
panelists get ready, we're going
to show you coverage from the
Watergate hearings.  We've just
launched a curated exhibit on
the  AAPB website about public
broadcasting's  coverage of the
Watergate hearings, and that
will mark the first time the
complete online access to the
hearings has been made available
to the public online.
>> SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everyone.  I'm the
chairman of the executive
advisory council for the
American Archive of Public
Broadcasting, and when I arrived
at WGBH, Henry  Morganthal was
in his heyday as an executive
producer, so he was one of my
mentors, and one thing that
Carla Hayden didn't have time to
tell you is he still have the
urge to create, he's just
published a book of his poetry,
his first book of poetry, I've
got a copy over there, and what
she didn't tell you is this is
actually a stop on his book tour
today.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: It is my great
pleasure to introduce this next
panel and its moderator, Judy
Woodrough, one of our very
special colleagues in public
media.  Judy began her
distinguished career at the CBS
affiliate in Atlanta and went on
to be White House correspondent
for NBC, was the host of
Frontline in its early days,
host of Inside  Politics for
CNN, guest correspondent for NPR
and chairperson of the
International Women's  Media
Foundation and has been honored
by many distinguished
organizations.  So, thank you,
Judy, for helping us today, and
we promise to get you out of
here and back ready to prep for
the news hour tonight.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you very much
.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Henry Beckton, of
course, being one of the pillars
for public media for so many
years, um, Boston and the whole
country has so much to thank you
for.  Thank you,  Henry.  So,
I'm the lucky one now, because I
get to preside over this panel
of five mega stars in public
media, the pantheon of news and
public affairs.  Each one of
them has played an absolutely
essential role in keeping public
media, public television, and
radio at the center of American
life.  Um, none of them needs an
introduction, so I'm going to
be very brief, starting with my
mentor, um, the man you just saw
in that clip, the former anchor
and executive editor of the
news hour with Jim  Larer, and
before that, the co-anchor and
executive editor of the McNeal
News Hour, the face of and the
singular
driving force behind daily
journalism at PBS, Jim Larer.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Next, the President
and CEO of WETA since 1989.
Before that, she served as a
member and chair of the board of
Corporation for Public
Broadcasting, as well as the
member of the WETA board,
following her service on the
West Virginia Educational
Broadcasting  Authority, Sharon
Percy-Rockefeller.  The
Executive Director and co-found
er of the  national Latino
Public Radio Network in 1976, he
was the moving force of a group
of Latino farm workers,
artists, activists, and teachers
who founded this in California
Valley,
Hugo  Moralis.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Someone who's
already been applauded here,
the long-time host of the Dick
Kavitz show, has spanned
networks from NBC,  USA, HBO,
and of course, PBS.  He's
appeared in movies, TV specials,
and several Broadway  plays,
Dick Kavit.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Finally, the
aforementioned living legend,
the woman who moderated the last
panel
and commentator for ABC News,
advisor to the American Archives
of Public Broadcasting,
Coce Roberts.  So, what we're
charged with doing is looking at
how news and public affairs
came into being and how it
evolved in public media.  Jim,
I'm going to start with you.
You were there almost at the
beginning.  When you came to
Washington, it was all about
Watergate.  What happened?
>> SPEAKER: Well, the Watergate
hearings really did, that was
the watershed event for news and
public affairs on public
television.  Up to that point,
the, um, the stations and the
public was generally divided
over whether you even
needed anymore news and public
affairs on television beyond
what was already there on
commercial television.  The
Nixon  Administration
particularly didn't think there
was a need for anymore news and
public affairs on public
broadcasting, but the Watergate
hearings changed everything,
and the reason it changed was
because of, there's several
individuals who had the courage
to make some really tough
decisions, and one of them was
not to necessarily broadcast
them gavel to gavel, because
many of the stations would not
broadcast it live, because they
had educational TV on during the
daytime, but somebody, and I
was part of the mix of the
somebodies, said why in the hell
don't we run them at night?
Repeat them at night?  And that
was a big, big deal.  It was a
big decision, and, um, the
people who were running PBS were
nervous about it, so they said
let's poll the stations, so but
the, we did poll the stations,
but we polled the stations in a
very clever way.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: We polled the
stations with a question that
was kind of phrased in such a
way, do you want to be
patriotic, or do you want to be
a jerk.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And we still barely
won.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And, um, but as
McNeal said at the time, and I
quote him almost verbatim, um,
well, the option, because it was
summertime, and PBS didn't
have that much to run at night,
they had no original programs to
run at night anyhow, so he
said, well, all they would run,
if they didn't run the hearings,
would be, how did he put it um,
English-speaking people
talking, animals  mating.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And occasionally,
English-speaking people mating
and animals  talking.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: So, why not replace
it with the Watergate hearings?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: That's why when I
said 3:00 a.m., the hearings
weren't going on till 3:00 a.m.,
that was the repeat every night
.  We would do it live all day,
but we only had  about, maybe
half the stations were watching
it, were broadcasting it, but
at night, um, and at first, it
wouldn't, you know, it was the
old story, you know, um, the big
stations wouldn't take it, but
then they started, because the
word got out, and then suddenly,
it became a big deal, and the
big deal was that it proved,
beyond a shadow of a doubt, that
there was a role for news and
public affairs on public
broadcasting because of those
hearings.
>> SPEAKER: So, when you and
Robin cooked up the McNeal
Report, then quickly --
>> SPEAKER: It began, as I said
a million times, it began with
the worst title in the history
of television, and I was the
Washington correspondent, and
then it became, my mother
interceded.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: It was one story a
day for 30 minutes when we
started, and then, that was 75,
and then 83, it went to an hour.
>> SPEAKER: And that's where I
want to bring in Sharon
Rockefeller, because Sharon, you
were already active in public
broadcasting, and you knew what
Jim and Robin were trying to do.
What were you up against when
they tried to go to an hour?
>> SPEAKER: The stations, in
many senses.  Um, I was working,
I was familiar with West
Virginia Education Broadcasting
Authority, not on the board at
that time, because my husband
wasn't governor, and that was a
governor appointment.  At the
time, actually, I asked for one
thing from my husband, can I be
appointed to the
WVEBA, and he said yes, and no
one ever thought twice about it,
but that was my training,
that's where I learned, but the
Watergate hearings, actually, I
watched every single day, all
day long.  Jay had lost an
election by the largest margin
in the history of the state.  We
had four years in
exsile in  West Virginia, three
hours north of Charleston,
three hours south of Pittsburgh,
about an hour and a half from
the Morgantown West Virginia
University Station, so when the
Watergate  hearings were on, I
could not receive the Washington
Post by mail until two days
after it was published, I
started watching full-time.  My
kids were watching Sesame
Street.  I loved history, but
news and public affairs was my
main attraction, it was what we
had to offer.  We, at that
point, was little ole public
television, and it was the
turnaround.  I also came on the
WETA board at the same time
through another vehicle, a
friend of mine on the Stanford
University Board, which had one
woman on the board, and I was
taking her place.  She was the
founder of, this is in the
70s, she was the founder of
Caroline Charles.  So, she said
where do you live, I said West
Virginia, and she said, where is
that?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: She said is it near
the Dakotas?  I said no.  Is it
near the Carolinas?  No.  Um,
but she knew Mrs.  Campbell, and
she called her immediately, I
was 29, she said you have to
talk to this young woman.  I
didn't know what about, but Mrs.
Campbell called me, in a very
authoritarian way, you must come
to Washington right now, which
I did.  I've always taken my
orders from Elizabeth Campbell,
and that's how I got involved
with WETA.  So, I had a very
small poor rural state, and at
that point, WETA was not as
wealthy as it is today, it had a
budget of $4 million, now we're
at $97 million, but we've
clawed our way up, and it's
really through news and public
affairs.  The Watergate hearings
put public television on the
map, and WETA, and The News
Hour, which came about in 1983,
because we thought we should be
the
first and that all stations
were going to go to one hour of
news.  In fact, they never did.
We did, but we won, if you
recall,  Robin and Jim and I
went around to visit stations,
speak to them
.
>> SPEAKER: We divided up the
300-some public television
stations, and, um, we called
every station manager or program
manager, because, um, the
President of PBS said, well,
it's a great idea to go to an
hour, but I don't have the power
to do it, you're going to have
to get the stations to do it, so
we physically called them on
the phone, and then there was a
vote, and we won by six votes.
>> SPEAKER: That's right.
>> SPEAKER: To go to an hour.
>> SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
>> SPEAKER: And out of
300-something.
>> SPEAKER: Exactly.
>> SPEAKER: I felt like, oh,
never mind.
>> SPEAKER: All you need is one
more.
>> SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Democracy run.
>> SPEAKER: So, while all this
was going on in the daily news,
daily journalism world, you had
a very successful career as an
interviewer in commercial
television.  What was the appeal
of public television?
>> SPEAKER: Well, I noticed
that among the things they
thought might
come up would be the question
of why I moved my show from, um,
network television to PBS.  I
was fired.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: That'll do it
.
>> SPEAKER: That's pretty much
what happened.  So, that kind of
, um, opened the door, paved the
way.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Whatever cliche you
prefer.  It was a wonderful
change
.  I was, of course, delighted
to get a show, terrified and
very nervous at first, and the
trouble there, the kind that
would come up on network, so-
called non-public television, so
to speak, started on the first
day.  I thought I had a
wonderful show to present them
as my first show, to be played
about a week later.  Mohammed
Ali, Angela Lanesbury, did a
wonderful, lively show, and
foolish boy from Nebraska that I
am
, I went back stage to be
congratulated by ABC Vice
President, and I saw his
expression didn't seem
appropriate for a show that he
loved.  I think it was worded
who the, let's say hell, um,
gives a damn, that's a better
word, what Mohammed Ali and Gora
Vedal think about  Vietnam?
Obviously, that had come up.
Second brilliant part of his
reaction was we can't really air
that as the first show because
of that, and we're going to air
it as the second show, and I
seem to remember saying, are you
going to be like this all along
?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I saw Agent Sam
McCone wince over in the corner,
and they did that.  I did a
second show that was nice.  We
had them both, and they aired
the second show first, and it
got mildly enthusiastic
reaction, and then they aired
the first show the second night,
and reviewers were reviewing
the whole week.  Almost
everybody said about the second
show, the Kavit Show really
found itself on the second show.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I was sure that,
the man who had been waiting
back stage to congratulate me
got a copy of that.  So, that
sort of thing happened, and then
there were other kinds of
troubles that I would not have
gotten on, and didn't, on PBS.
One involved that lovable old
couple, the John Lenins, and
they came on, and other people
were jealous, and the reviews
and ratings were big, and that
was nice, and they even came
back.  John, when I met him a
week earlier, said, I said why
do you want to do this, really?
There can't be much you need at
this point, and he said, well,
you have the  only halfway
intelligent show on television,
and I said, why would you want
to be on a  halfway intelligent
show?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: He laughed, as many
of you did, and we were friends
from that point on, but on the
second show, who would have
guessed, the agreement had been
that we would do one of their
songs, and John said, well, do
one of  Yoku's songs, and it had
the catchy title Woman is the
Nigger of the World, and, um, I
thought
, by god, we did this song, and
nothing happened, but before it
was aired, I was told that it
would not be aired, the song,
and I complained, and they said,
well, all right, we will air
it, but our decision is that you
will make a statement
beforehand about the dangers of
watching it, I guess.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I remember one of
the, well, oh, and there were
412, perhaps, protests about
the song.  None of them about
the song though, but as one
woman put it, about that mille-
mouth speech you delivered.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: My delivery sort of
encouraged that, I think.  So,
getting to PBS was going into a
green meadow, in a way.
>> SPEAKER: Well, I want to
hear more about the green meadow
, but Coce, I want to come to
you, because we heard Bill
Simmering say words to the
effect that they felt that NPR
should have had a, the early
head-start that  PBS did.  Did
you feel that?
>> SPEAKER: Oh, sure. It's
still true, to some degree, but
it turned out to be a  blessing,
I think, and Bill can probably
talk about this more, that it
was kind of a secret at first,
because at the point when Nixon
did go after television, and
basically, the television
network committed suicide, NPR
was still there, and there was
no necessity to disband it,
because it wasn't on the radar,
and, so, um,
the ability to just grow and
thrive was much easier in that
environment, but then the
growing and thriving, um, became
something quite dramatic, and
as of today, we are listened to
by more people than the three,
you know, it's listened to by
more people than the three
network morning shows combined.
It is listened to by more
people other than anything but
Rush Limbal.  The difference in
ratings is about a half a
million people
.  So, it is wildly successful,
and really, the primary source
of news for millions of people
around the world.
>> SPEAKER: And commercial
radio has  pulled back from this
dramatically over the years.
>> SPEAKER: That's also true.
>> SPEAKER: Leaving a big
opening.  So, you were paying
attention to all this in
California, but you and some of
your friends, um, decided there
was something missing.  What did
you see?
>> SPEAKER: Well, first of all,
there was little, at that time,
little or no news on radio, and
that is true today
.  Spanish language commercial
radio, there is no news.  I
mean, it sounds maybe sort of
shocking, most of us believe in
the mission, but it's absent.
It's a shocking truth, that
there is no news in Spanish
language radio, and when we got
started back in
76, we got started on July 4th,
1980.  The population of
Latinos in the U.S. was around
15 million, which is around 6.5
percent of the U.S. population.
Now, it's 58 million, and 18
percent of the population,  and
72 percent of Latinos speak
Spanish at home home.  So, this
is not something of the past.
You know, some of us were young
at that time, right?  And we had
big dreams, but rather it's
something that is very relevant
today, and yet there is no news
in Spanish language commercial
radio.
>> SPEAKER: Stunning.
>> SPEAKER: Very stunning.
It's a story that, um, some of
us don't want to, perhaps,
believe, but it is true, and,
um, so, back  in 1976, when we
started organizing, I started
organizing
this in Fresno, um, you know,
it's a community that I came to,
because I was born in esh
raised in Sonoma County, where
the fires were recently, and
then went to the Silicon  Valley
.  You know, it's, the amount of
people that I came in contact
with, they saw the same thing,
all these Mexican Americans, all
of us, all of them were
U.S.-born, except for me, I was
the only immigrant, and all of
us were bilingual
and educated.  We were the
first generation of Latinos to
be opened the doors to higher
education.  So, that contributed
a lot to why it was founded,
because we saw this degree of
limitation of public
broadcasting, but not just
public broadcasting, but, you
know, English language media
that we, as luteen ors or
asLatinos, could not access
because of the language, but not
just the language, and I see
everybody here, you know,
there's much more than the
language.  There's the culture,
the history, the nuances of
language, the literature, the
poetry, the arts, all that, and
that was absent in terms of, and
we, as young people, thought,
well, wow, you know, it seems
like our treasures, our
community treasures are hidden
treasures.  We have so much, um,
you know, wealth of history, we
have so much wealth of art and
so forth in our communities, and
we should be able to share that
and learn from one another.  So
, that's why we established this
in 1976, then went on the air
in 1980.
>> SPEAKER: And it's still
going?
>> SPEAKER: It's still going,
and we also believed public
affairs had to be part of it,
because what we wanted to do is,
just like in this situation, we
wanted, um, us, as Mexican
Americans and Latinos, to tell
the story, have our own
narrative, to be inclusive.  I
mean, if you look at, for
example, the prison population
today in the United States, you
know, something like 19 percent
of the, um, imprisoned
population in the U.S. is Latino
.  So, a lot of our communities
in need.  The highest drop-out
rates from high schools continue
to be Latinos in the United
States, and yet you see the
figures of how a significant
number of Latinos, and we're
projected to grow even larger.
So, that's why we founded it,
because we wanted that to
happen.  So, we've been able to
document and follow some of the
stories that some of the other
media have not.  For example,
there's a case of, um, of an
indigenous woman living in the
south, who was the, you know,
parenting her child
, not parenting her child at
birth because she could not
communicate in English or
Spanish, because she spoke a
native language from my home
state.  So, it's, um, you know,
it's that kind of a case, where
some community, um, folks there
from, I think it was Alabama,
called our station and told them
the story, and we broke the
story, and the mainstream media
picked it up, and eventually,
she recovered her child, but
that's the kind of stories that
we recover, or right now, what's
happening, talk about the need,
there's, um, a lot of fear
among our families about, you
know, deportations, and maybe to
those of us in this room, it's
just another topic, but to
people who listen to us, our
listeners, it's very, very
personal.  I mean, just, um, I
think about a month, a couple
months ago, we had a call from,
um, a mother from Tracy,
California, when we opened the
lines, and we were also giving
out information at that time,
and she was saying that her son
had gone into depression after
the election.  He knew what was
about to happen, and he was a
DACA recipient, and he had quit
his college upon, after the
election, and then soon, later,
he quit his job.  So, the mother
was very worried about her son
and what was about to happen.
So, this is the kind of stories
and narratives that are carried.
>> SPEAKER: You're touching,
um, stories of all American
lives, and that's what public
broadcasting, public media, was
founded to do.  Jim, let's talk
next, um, for a few minutes
about how hard, or not, it's
been to survive as public media,
as news and public affairs in
public media.
A lot of competition out
there.  The news, the commercial
news environment has changed so
drastically.  Um, why has
public media remained, news and
public affairs  remained as
strong as it has, do you think?
>> SPEAKER: Well, first of all,
McNeal and I said at the very
beginning, um, that if people
started, if commercial
television came along, when
cable started growing, in fact,
particularly, if they started
doing what we're doing, we'd
quit doing it.  There's no point
in our doing, um, what's
already, what's available else
where.  We'll go on and do
something else, and, um, we had
a lot of ideas of other things
that we could do, but as we sit
here now, nobody's done it, and,
um, in fact, there is more, now
more than ever, they would say,
the kind of journalism that is
practiced on the news hour is
more needed now than ever
before, because journalism on
television has had its own
growth and its own kinds of, um,
changes, and those changes have
been away from the kind of
separation of straight reporting
, from analysis, from opinion,
that sort of thing, which is
still true of the news hour, but
not true in some elements of
commercial television,
particularly cable television,
and, so, the reason for our
being, let's just cut to the
chase, the reason for our being
is stronger now than it has ever
been
.
>> SPEAKER: Good point.
>> SPEAKER: We'll let that just
sit  there, because I think
it's right.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: But Sharon, as
somebody who has to look at this
both, you know, as you know
journalists very well, but you
have to think about it as a
manager, as an executive, how
hard has it been to keep news
and public affairs going?  And
we should add, you oversee  The
Ken Burns, it's not just The
News Hour and Washington Week,
it's that show and many  others.
>> SPEAKER: Well, I think one
of the things that's great about
the public television audience
is that it's pretty
well-educated.  Above all, it
continues to want to learn.  So,
keeping up on a daily basis is
important, but putting in
context weekly, as we do on
Washington Week, is very
important, and  history, the
arts, science, kids, all of the
rest means we serve so many
different people in so many
different ways, but our
signature is the news and public
affairs.  It's the hardest to
fund, and yet our membership
money essentially helps
subsidize, although we raise a
lot for the news hour, we raise
a good bit for Washington Week,
but we never make a  profit,
let's put it that way, we always
reinvest in the product and
could spend a lot more than we
take in.  I think it is our
trademark, our signature.  We're
very proud of it, and I think
our audience is proud to be
associated with what we do.
>> SPEAKER: But it's always
been difficult to keep it
funded.  Always.  We've never
had, we don't even, the word
surplus doesn't even, it's not
even in our vocabulary.  We're
always either over budget or
having to cut back, and that's
been from day one, and I hate to
say this, but, um, at the very
beginning, when we first
started, which was now 38 years
ago, there was a commercial
television guy named Marvin
Kalb, I ran into him socially,
we'd been on the air a year or
two at that point, and I didn't
know Marvin  Kalb, and he said,
yeah, well, you guys are doing
things, but let me give you a
warning, and I said, what's
that?  He said don't let them
give you too much money, and I
said, that's not a problem, but
just for the hell of it, tell
me why, and he told a quick
story, and he had scads of them,
but one in particular, um, CBS
News,
he was going to do a minute and
a half, it was going to be a
major story, they kept cutting
it back, complainting cutting it
back, and a minute or two
before air, they got some great
fire footage from downtown
Little Rock.  Now, nobody was
hurt in the fire, just great
pictures of fires, and they cut
his report back to 20 seconds,
and he said if they hadn't had
the money to buy that fire
footage, I would have had my
minute and a half.  So, and it
was, but it was, clearly, it
stuck in my mind, because I just
told the story again, but it,
and McNeal always said that too,
you know, if you get too fat
and sassy, you will, you'll do
things that you will do, you'll
do things that you, that are not
required.  This way, when
you're limited by money, it
limits you to do what you must
rather than what you just kind
of want to do.
>> SPEAKER: Well, in radio,
that's really not true, because
what we're doing is opening
bureaus all over the place, and
when we're living in a world
where what happens in sin tog
muSquare in Athens affects your
401K, then you need to have more
international coverage rather
than less, and of course, more
national  coverage,
understanding what's going on in
this country, and, so, really,
the money goes to those very
expensive foreign bureaus, which
are very, very difficult to do,
but I would argue it's
essential in this time.  So, we
need all the money we can get.
Thank you.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, it's probably
a story I shouldn't have told.
(Laughing.) speak
>> SPEAKER: The one thing I
would say is, um, that
corporations, in the early days,
we went to AT&T, etc., etc., we
got huge amounts of money in
retrospect.  That has diminished
drastically, but foundations
have really upped the ante, and
they understand, they're more
visionary, they have a lot of
money now, and it's not that
we've never had a surplus, but
foundations, and individuals,
who support the program now, we
have, you know, you can give as
an individual to support the PBS
News Hour, which was never
possible before, but we're doing
that in a membership kind of
way.
>> SPEAKER: Did the funding
situation affect the work you
were able to do, do you think,
in any way?  You, Dick.
>> SPEAKER: I recognize my
name.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Gee, I like fires.
>> SPEAKER: Um, I was never
thoughtful or thinking about
such things as funding.  That's
a bad habit, sort of frame of
mind for me, and I had to be
urged every now and then to make
a phone call or make an effort
or something like that, but I
was thinking of shows that I was
able to do.  People said, oh,
you're going into public
television now, that's for
intellectuals.  Intellectual is
a very dangerous label to have
put on you when you're in
television, whether it's public
or the other sort, but I
remember appreciating the fact
that ABC would have gotten a
little nervous when I would have
on England's great entertaining
performer/actor/philosopher
/teacher, Jonathan Miller, one
of the greatest intellectuals in
captivity, and would have him
on five nights in a row, and
people wanted more.  I can
imagine trying to do that, um,
else where.  So, I really wasn't
conscious of funding in ways
that probably were harmful to
me, because I'm sure I might
have been able to help with it,
if I had pitched in in certain
ways.
>> SPEAKER: But did you feel
the freedom to do pretty much
what you wanted when you were
working at PBS?  Interview the
people you  wanted and do the
kind of programming you  wanted
to do?
>> SPEAKER: Oh, I did. Yes. I
usually just did the kind of
programming I wanted to  do, and
I got away with it.  I'm not
aware of any particular gripes
of the sort I was used to on ABC
.
>> SPEAKER: Well, good. We'll
take that.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Am I disgustingly
happy?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: That's good.
>> SPEAKER: I'm going to come
back to  Hugo.  How do you see
this question of  resources?
How much of an issue is it?  Are
you able to ignore it?  I mean,
how does it affect what you're
able to do?
>> SPEAKER: Well, first of all,
I want to say that it's really,
really important that we
maintain that independence of
public  broadcasting, whether it
be on radio or television.
That's a value that we always
have shared and something we
have to be careful about.  So,
how do you build not just a
station, but in this case, a
network?  We  have 60
affiliates.  How do you build a
network when you're serving
people with, literally, no
disposable income, right?  I
mean, so, it's, you know, so,
part of it is the employees
subsidize the service in part,
which spans the history of
public television, public radio.
>> SPEAKER: Subsidize how?
>> SPEAKER: Lower salaries, for
example, for starters, and the
other is to be able to keep
those employees, you know,
that's a real, real challenge
for us.  Um, but the other is
that, um, it's foundations that
have, we manage to attract, but,
um, as the competition for that
has grown, our share of that
has gone lower for public
affairs and for news and
information from the foundation
ations.  So, it's really, really
difficult for us, and, so, I
would say that for news
information in Spanish, it's
really difficult for us to
maintain that.
>> SPEAKER: So, that leads to
my last question.  How do you
see the future of news?  The
future of public affairs in
radio and television.  Do you
feel confident about it?  I
mean, I like to feel very
confident about it, because
wherever I go, I get, I hear
good  things about The News
Hour, but what do you feel?
What do you hear?
>> SPEAKER: I think that, um,
one of the things that we're
learning is that Congress
actually likes NPR, and they
can't always say it out loud,
but, um, the truth is is that,
um, it gets back to what Nick
was saying earlier, they're all,
you know, they're on, and it's
in all of their districts, and
it is the source of news, but,
of course, the federal funding
is a tiny percentage of NPR
money, it's really just for the
satellite, but the stations rely
on it a lot, particularly the
small rural stations, and that's
an important thing to keepin
mind, that these are people who
really are desperate for this
kind of information, and
sometimes, it's also the only,
um, emergency signal, you know,
all of that, and, so, um, I
think that the fact of the
service is so widespread and
diverse and so well listened to
by people in all areas of
American life that I feel very
confident about the future, but
I do think it requires resources
.
>> SPEAKER: I was going to say
that the last two years, the
last year and a half have proven
more than ever the need for
what we do.  It is so complex,
depressing to many, hopeful to
those who thought they were
electing someone who would stand
for them, but the country is
changing so fast, the political
system is  practically
impossible to understand.  We,
despair being
despair being ungovernable, but
who brings some sense and order
and rationale to what happened
today and this week and this
year, plus analysis, plus
thoughtful, complex, sensitive,
um, ideas about what might
happen in the  future, we are
doing that in a way that nobody
else is, and if we just stay
true to our mission, stick to
the straight and narrow, I think
we've got a great future in
news and public affairs.
>> SPEAKER: I agree 100
percent.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Every one of us --
, I was just going to say amen
and add a couple lines.  The
basic need for the free press
was setup by the founders, and
the key to our Democratic
society is an informed
electorate, an informed public.
The only device that the
founders created through the
First Amendment was the free
press.  That's the device for
people to get  information, to
cast and form votes, and all
levels in government, and we
are, what we, public
broadcasting, but we in
journalism, we who facilitate it
and practice it and participate
in it at any level are part of
a Democratic process that is
particularly  critical right now
with this explosion of
information that's coming out,
with the tsunami of electronic
this and that gadget and this
and all this stuff, this is a
critical time, and I agree with
what Sharon said, we must not
lose sight of what our purpose
is, and it isn't about making
people laugh, it isn't about
people making, making them cry,
it's about  keeping them
informed enough to function as
informed people in this country,
informed citizens.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you.
Dick?
>> SPEAKER: I, too, agree with
Sharon on that, particularly in
this, um--
>> SPEAKER: You don't agree
with me?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I'll get to you in
a minute.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Um, as we are all
living in this seeming time of
plague, um, certainly, there has
to be the service that only
public broadcasting can do so
well and continue to be the
great garden of thrilling,
varied, wonderful things that
are not available else where on
television.  They're still not
beholden, and they are, public
television is still vital to our
lives.  Sounds corny, but I
believe it.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: If you're not
optimistic, you can't speak.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I am, and I agree
with, um, these distinguished
panelists, and in terms of, um,
Spanish language news and
information, I think the need is
there for basic information,
along with, you know, news and
information to the Latino
community, and I think the
future, um, for Spanish language
media is to be able to
communicate that at forums, so
thank you for the invitation,
um, of what the reality is and
the need for that, because it's
so critical, and, so, thank you
very, very much.
>> SPEAKER: So critical. I
just want to thank all of the
panelists, but I also want to
quickly read a little bit of an
e-mail, um, we at The News Hour
got yesterday from our
colleague, Jeff Brown, who had
been  interviewing inmates at
San Quintin Prison for a story
they're working on about a
podcast they're producing, which
is going to appear, but what I
want to share with you is Jeff
wrote all of us to say that
several dozen inmates in
different parts of the prison,
different  places, from
different parts of the country,
came up to him and the crew
while they were there to say,
hey, PBS, we don't know what we
would do without PBS.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: They went on to say
how much the program means.
While Jeff is interviewing an
inmate in one cell, they can
hear the program in the next
cell being listened to, so I
just want to say that we are, we
reach people in public media in
every corner of this  country.
We're not just in the intellec
tual capitols and the political
capitols and the places of great
wealth, we are in parts of the
country where people are
struggling and trying to get
their lives back together, and
those are the stories that we
will always tell, along with all
the others.  So, what an
amazing  panel.  Thank you.
>> SPEAKER: If they were, some
of those inmates were to, um,
join their local public
broadcasts, it would be a
wonderful funding.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: We thought about
that.
>> SPEAKER: I will tell you one
quick story, because it gets to
the excellent point you just
made.  At one point, when Susan
Stanburg was the regular host
of All Things  Considered, and
she took a leave to write a
book, a farmer wrote to her and
said my cows won't give milk.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And he was always
going into the milking barn and
turning on All Things
Considered, and they heard Susan
and gave milk.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And without Susan,
no milk.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Okay. We've heard
it.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you all.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you,
everybody, and thank you to the
panels.  We're going to take a
short
break now.  However, we hope
you will stay to watch some of
the clips we've put together to
wrap-up this previous panel and
launch the next panel, which is
documentary, style, and use of
archives, which will begin at
4:00 o'clock.  Thank you.
>> SPEAKER: If everyone
could get to their seats and
settle down so we can start the
next session
.  If everybody could take their
seats so we could get started.
Could everyone get seated,
please?
There are more seats upfront
now, since some of the speakers
have left, if people want to
fill in
.  We're going to get started
now, so if people could sit
down.  We're not on as tight of
a schedule, because Judy is
going to make it to The News
Hour, but we would still like to
keep the time.
Our next panel is called
documentaries:  Style and the
use of archives, and Pat
Aufderheide will moderate.  She
is a communications professor at
American University in
Washington, DC.  She founded the
school center for media and
social impact.  Her books
include  Reclaiming Fair Use,
How to Put Balance Back In
Copyright.  She coordinates the
free speech --  Pat, take it
away.
>> SPEAKER: What a great
pleasure it is.  I feel like my
entire life is passing before me
as I look around the crowd, but
this, to be on a panel with
these people is really
extraordinary.  Um, each of the
people here has been able to not
merely make great documentary,
but create a future for a
different kind of documentary
than was ever possible on any
other kind of television to be
made, and each of them has, um,
has contributed differently to
doing that, and also, in some
cases, supporting each other,
which is really, um, I don't
know if I'm giving away secrets
here, but that doesn't always
happen in public television.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Anyway, um, and
I've had the pleasure of working
with some of these people as
well, because, um, as Karen
mentioned, over the last decade,
Peter and I have been working
with different organizations to
make fair use more available,
particularly in archival ways,
to, um, to makers and public TV
broadcasters, including some of
these people have really  been,
um, incredibly supportive and
early  adopters in being able to
make, um, better use of
material, third-party material
to tell America's story in so
many different ways.  I want to
start, first, with Clayborne
Carson.  So, Clayborne Carson is
the founder, director of the
Martin Luther King, Jr. Research
and  Education Institute.  He,
um, was the senior advisor for
Eyes On The Prize at a time when
no one thought it could be made
.  I would like to ask each of
you, starting with Clayborne, to
talk about what did you have in
mind for these series, each of
you have this experience, of
these series that ended up
really providing a template for
how to do things in the future
for
film makers that really hadn't
been done.
>> SPEAKER: To start out, one
of the things that's so
interesting, to listen to the
previous panel, is that, um, you
know, just yesterday, I was
lecturing at Stanford to my
students who were born well
after all this had happened,
and, um, I think that they were
telling me about a period
before I came on the scene, so I
suddenly felt younger, in the
sense that when, um, I was, I
got a call from Henry  Hampton,
who should be here.  He,
unfortunately, passed away, died
way too early, but he was the
visionary
, and I had just  accepted an
invitation to edit Martin Luther
King's papers, so it wasn't
like I was looking for work.  I
realized that this was going to
take decades, and it has taken
decades, to edit and publish his
papers, but what he was, he
talked about his idea for a
series, and I think one of the
themes that I see running
through all the discussions this
afternoon is about democrat
ization of information and the
interpretation of history
, of the way in which, if you
think back to the days before
PBS, before NPR, before the
modern documentary  style, most
information about the past came
from a few sources.  If you saw
a documentary, it was usually
made by a, well, they didn't
have large-scale documentaries
made by anything other than
large corporations.  A lot of
them, things like CBS Reports,
things like that, they were done
by the commercial networks, and
what he was proposing was to do
something very  radical, and
that is to get away from the
notion of history as a master
narrative told by a handful of
people and written in textbooks
andbooks, and everyone kind of
took that as  authoritative.
One of the first things he said
is there's not going to be any
what we now call talking heads
in Eyes On The Prize, that our
job was not to come there and
pontif Kate, and, you know, the
four of us who were the senior
advisors were all really young,
and I don't think we would have
welcomed that role in the first
place, but what our job was, to
go and find how history was made
during the nineteen 60s, fifty
and
fifty and 60s, and to go to the
sources and find those people
and let them tell the story of
how they made history, not to
interpret it
.
>> SPEAKER: That was a
breakthrough.
>> SPEAKER: Yes, because even
now, when you look at
documentaries, you see that many
of them kind of go back to that
notion, by having the
authoritative historian kind of
give this interpretation that's
going to guide you through, but
there's this other story of
these ordinary people who make
history
, and the real joy of doing it
was that for us, as historians,
we were in our own work, you
know, my first book was on the
student on violent coordinating
committee, which was not about
King, it was kind of the
counter-King story.  So, I
welcome that kind of an
approach, and I think that that
has influenced the documentaries
that have been made since then
, that many of them do take up
that mantle of allowing ordinary
people to tell the story of
making history.
>> SPEAKER: From what you're
telling me as well, not that,
so, one characteristic, this is
ordinary people telling this
story, and  also, in an oral
history way.  I mean, there was
so much rich oral history that
had not, that would have escaped
us forever.
>> SPEAKER: And now it's
interesting, because I can go
into
my classroom and use those, um,
interviews.  I rarely use Eyes
On  The Prize, but I use the
interviews we did, and often,
that works so much better in the
sense that it'll, I get it to
the point where it fits what I
want to talk about.  If I want
to talk about
Karetta Scott King, for
example, there's this wonderful
extended interview we did with
her, where maybe we used, at
most, 5 minutes of it, and I
find that my students are so
drawn to just seeing her talk
about ordinary things, you
knowerse
you know, what was it like
talking to the President of the
United States when
your husband is in jail, and
you've never spoken to him
before, and he calls on the
phone, and your young son
answers the phone and starts
babbling away, and you have to
kind of get him off and say the
President's there, and, um, you
know, that kind of a story is
going to get through and stick
in the minds of students far
more than simply me giving a
lecture about Martin Luther King
, going to jail and writing the
letter from Birmingham jail.
>> SPEAKER: Something else I
think was so important about
eyes on the prize in terms of
standard-setting was really
arguing that every single image
had to be exactly what you
claimed it was.  It couldn't be,
like, something that looked
sort of like that, which was
very common common.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. There was no
reconstruction.  We had to, and
in fact, that was when, there's
a story, actually, that kind of
illustrates that.  We were
interviewing Ralph Abernathy
about the March on Washington,
and he told this wonderful story
about coming back after that
day at the march, I was there
too
, and it had particular meaning
when he  talked about coming
back after all the people had
departed, and in the evening,
seeing the rustling of the
papers and all the leftover
things, and then he says, you
know, it was just the most
beautiful day of my entire life,
and I remember David Garro, um,
kind of saying but it couldn't
have happened that way.  Why?
Because we know where Ralph
Abernathy was every moment of
that day.  So, we had this
debate about whether to trust
his recollection as opposed to
our historical reconstruction,
and, um, we decided to use it.
We said history might not have
happened that way, maybe it
should have.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Let me jump to
David, if you don't mind, who I
remember when he was the brash,
young Australian
.  South Africa, sorry
.  Us Americans, what's the
difference?
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Here to bring us a
whole new, um, format that was
possibly too challenging for
public television.
>> SPEAKER: You know, I'm a
creature of, I'm a baby of
public television.  I walked
into a television station in
1973 in Huntington Beach, and I
walked in and volunteered, got
my hands on the tools, that
camera that was there and began
working there.  Peter McGuire
McGhee found me there in 1977
and brought me to start a
series, and the idea was to do a
series about the world as
others see it, and I came to
WBGH to find a place that was
this extraordinary institution
that was dedicated to ideas, and
I had never been around
anything quite like it.  It was
also that each of the people
that were working in the
different genres, from signs to
history to, um, even Julia
Child, who was in the back
corner of our offices, um, were
doing things because of, um,
they cared about the ideas,
and, um, it was an extraordinary
privilege, and it is to this
day, this amazing privilege.
The reason there's a Frontline
is because we were trusted with
enough resources for long enough
to work it out, to try to
figure out how to do the best
work, and the privilege of being
able to give them that resource
and to say how are you going to
spend it and justify it, and if
you can't make the best film
you could make about the
subject, then don't make it, and
it was as simple as that.  It
wasn't me, it was all the
talented people that I could go
out and bring to public
television.  I tried that out.
We did 60 films along the way,
but there was a moment when I
sat in a meeting at the
Corporation of Public
Broadcasting, with a man who
must be remembered, Lewis
Freedman was then the head of,
um, of programming, and he had
walked into it, and he said he
was inenidated with thousands of
proposals, and he just couldn't
sort through it all, and he
made a decision to do three big
strands.  One was going to be
drama, and it became American
Playhouse.  The second was
Children's, and it became
Wonder-works, and the third was
a news and documentary idea, and
I walked in looking for a
little bit of funding to do
eight shows for the next
seasons, and he made me sit down
at his table with a sandwich
and figure out what the budget
for a 26-week series would look
like, and we counted it up to $3
million at the time in
1981, and we came up with that
figure and said, well, we could
probably do it for that much
money, and he said, great, I'm
going to put out a request for
proposals, and he put out a
proposal to various people, and
we proposed it and got the
money, and the guarantee was
that we would have the money for
three years, if we could
persuade the stations to match
the money progressively over the
course of the three years.  It
was a visionary idea, and it
left us the freedom to do that,
and we made our mistakes, and
we, you know, bumped our heads,
and we did some good things and
found some smart people, and
slowly, this idea grew.  So, to
Lewis, to Peter McGhee, who
found me on the beach and
brought me to Boston, you know,
are the people I thank for
Frontline.  That's what made it
happen, and, um, it really has
been, um, as simple as that and
as  complicated as that.
>> SPEAKER: Although Frontline
has
, it developed almost a brand,
that you really did put your
stamp on a kind of documentary
--
>> SPEAKER: But I'd like to say
that the films were very, well,
I don't know, see, I think
there were lots and lots of
different styles of films within
them.  They were observational
films, investigative films, they
were, um, films like, um, you
know,
there were extraordinarily
different films that came
about, and I always thought that
we needed to make the series
that young and older producers,
reporters, and film makers would
look at and say I can learn
from that, and the people would
come to me and say how do you
make these films, I'd like to
get into documentaries, I'd say
just watch a lot of them and try
to deconstruct them and look
for the different ones that suit
you for who you are and the
kind of film you make, because
ultimately, these are works of
authorship, and if you encourage
authors and then encourage them
because they do good work by
giving them another film to
make, then you begin to build a
body of work over time.
Frontline has, initially, we,
um, you know, Judy was anchoring
the series after Jessica
Sabage, but at a certain point,
we felt like, um, we would sort
of take the extra time, and we
began to use Will Limen as a
voice, and we made that
strategic decision, that there
would be something in the
quality of the words, or the
quality of the story-telling
that would say that's that
different thing, that's that
show, and, so, there was a value
to that.  There were people who
questioned that Will is kind of
old-fashioned and, um, the
patriarchy and all kinds of
reasons that people would say we
should be using other voices,
and we do, but ultimately, you
needed to have some kind of
connective tissue at times that
would hold the string through
the sets of films.
>> SPEAKER: So, you're arguing
if you could have some of these
marking features, then you could
have a lot more freedom,
artistic freedom in other areas.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, but something
other than an anthology series,
and the most important thing
about it was it was going to be
a work of journalism, not an
anthology series made by
independent film makers who
would come to us with
films pretty much made, we
would initiate and subject them
to the an editorial process,
which meant that the journalism
had to be transparent, and we
needed to be, go right deep into
it at any point and be able to
understand the source materials
inside that film, and that was
at the heart of Frontline.
>> SPEAKER: Margaret wants to
--
>> SPEAKER: Margaret
I also wanted to add that there
is another binding agent in
Frontline, and when I came here,
I discovered this, because I
had come from CBS, where I
worked at CBS Reports and then a
couple of iterations of
magazine shows, and, um, CBS
Reports closed, shut down,
because, um, TV Guide, you
remember TV Guide?  An artifact
of the past.  They ran a
front-page story, I mean a cover
story saying the documentary is
dead, and this was in
1985.
>> SPEAKER: That's when
documentary was still a bad
word.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. So,
everybody went scurrying, and I
got a great job offer from Peter
McGhee, who really needs to be
mentioned as many times as
possible, because he sort of set
the standards at WGBH, and, um,
they  wanted, Peter and, Judy
Kriten was the original
executive producer, they wanted
to do a history series, but the
binding agent in the history
series
was good story-telling.  It had
to have a beginning, a middle,
and an end.  Narrative,
narrative, narrative.  We even
constructed the documentaries
an ax, which was something that
most had not been doing.  They
had, um, on commercial
television, you had a lot of
documentaries that were, like,
NBC White Paper and ABC, I
forget what that series was
called, and they were surveys.
They were mostly  surveys from
the top-down, they weren't
stories, they weren't actual
stories, where you had
characters that you could follow
, and I think, um, that was an
element that was emphasized at
GBH, and in particular, I know
at American Experience, because
as we were talking before, you
want to hear from as many people
as possible who are as close to
the subject as possible and
that construct it very carefully
to have a story arc, what
happened, then what happened
next, what happened after that.
>> SPEAKER: So, let's point out
then that public television is
the real innovator of this
character-driven story model
that now is standard expectation
for documentary.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, I think so,
because, I mean, I don't want to
take the credit for it, because
it was, I didn't invent the
narrative style, um, but it was
something that was embraced
whole-heartedly by WGBH, and
they gave all of us the
resources to figure it out,
because when you tell, when
you're in the process of telling
a story, you need time to
figure out what the story is,
who the main characters are, who
the secondary characters are,
where the break is, what's going
to happen next, how to conclude
it, and without being, um, you
don't have to tell the entire
story, because everybody used to
agonize about what's left out.
Well, if you did your job
properly, no one would even
notice notice that you left
anything out.  Our
philosophy was just go narrow
and go deep.  I did want to
comment on something you said
before about getting first-hand
witnesses, because I admired
that in, um, Henry Hampton's
shop and Eyes on the Prize, and
I thought it was terrific.  We
had a challenge, because our
mandate was to tell all American
history, you know, go back in
the 17th and 18th century, and
we were terrified.  We avoided
anything that was pre-archival
at the beginning, and you can't
find witnesses who were, one of
our first shows was on the 1906
San Francisco earthquake.  We
barely got a couple of people to
make an appearance, and as soon
as we found them, we shot them
immediately, you know, and put
them in the bank, because we
didn't even know we were going
to go ahead with this story, but
it was a real stretch for us,
and we had to challenge
ourselves to go back into the
19th century and even back into
the revolutionary period, so
what we relied on, since we're
here to talk about the archives,
is letters,  diaries,
first-hand accounts that could
then be employed in many
different ways to recall, maybe
it was the Donner Party, I mean,
you  know, there's no
first-hand witnesses there, one
of our most suck esful films,
and what did we rely on?
Diaries and letters.
>> SPEAKER: So, one of the
things that is so, um, I think
impressive about what both of
your series, and all of your
work in  documentaries did was
to, I think, create a sense of
trust among the stations, for
something that they had dreaded
and feared ever since the days
of NET, which was before there
was a PBS and, you know, shows
like the  red-lining show, so
you sort of created, um, a sense
of quality, dignity,
reliability,  turn-key and so on
.  Something else that is
actually really interesting to
me is that public television, in
building upon that, has been
able to actually foster a kind
of, um, and as you describe it,
anthology show for independent
voices as well, and impressively
, I have to say thank you to
David Fanning for being so
supportive of anthology shows,
as well as, um,
these executive-produced
journalism series, and Steven
Gong, one of the minority
consortia of
PPB, has also been involved in,
um, creating archives that we
can all draw on.  So, I'd love
to hear you talk a little bit
about the, um, film-making that
goes to fuel the two big
anthology series, POV and
independent lens
.
>> SPEAKER: Actually, if I
could, I'd like to make a
reference to the panels we heard
earlier, because the seeds of
the minority consortia,
independent and diverse film
-makers really goes back to the
same era of the great society,
so many of these entities were
founded in the 70s, and it came
out of both Civil  Rights, and
in many of our cases, Moralis
touched on this also, of the
rapidly-changing demographics of
the country, which was starting
to be recognized even then.
You know, the  Immigration Act
was rewritten in 1965,and even
though it would take the rest of
the  generation, it has
reshaped America.  So, in this
time period I'm talking about,
the  Asian-American community
went from 1 percent of the
population, and now we're 6
percent,  over 20 million, and
it's growing, and he mentioned
the statistics for the Latino
community.  So, the premise that
we all had as this whole
enterprise was getting underway
was where were these voices of
other communities for whom our
presence in media overall was an
absence or was one of stereo
types.  So, for Asian-Americans,
in entertainment media, we are
only, you know, the villains in
war movies, or we're house boys
or gangsters in Chinatown or
laundrymen, and, um, and yet we
have this inspiration of the
Civil Rights Movement to
recognize how important it was
for us to be able to participate
in society.  So, the mechanism
for us in the minority consortia
and the wisdom for the
Corporation for Public
Broadcasting was to help ensure
that there was a pipeline of
programming by and about these
new minority communities, and
we'd been doing this between 35
and 40 years, all of us, the
five members of the
organization.  One of the things
that I, one of the first points
I want to make though, and in
response to your question, was
that we have learned something
deeper in this construct, that
it was important to, um, include
the perspectives of people of
color in telling, um, diverse
kinds of stories, be they about
history or social issues or even
our cultural history, and I
think at first, we thought we
were presenting authentic images
that our own communities could
recognize.  So, one piece that's
really important is you can't
fully participate in the society
unless, in some ways, you see
yourself and your stories told
in the society.  The second
point I think we came to
understand relatively quickly
after that was that these
stories needed to be for all
Americans though and not just
for our own communities.  The
Asian-American community would
be a good example, because we're
so diverse and so different in
language and cultural
backgrounds that in some ways,
where you know, you're an expert
in no other culture, in a sense
, in this construct of
Asian-America, but I would say
in the recent years, and this is
where I want to end my thoughts
on this, I think we now, where
we are today, in this question
of, really, who is an American
and what is it that makes
America great, it's clear that,
I think in some ways, we took
for granted that there was an
acceptance that diversity was an
important and a key factor of
the American experience, but it
is vital that we stand in for
this notion of what this country
can be and that we're not just
about our racial stories.  You
know, diversity is within each
of our communities as well, and
I think that's the larger piece
to reshift the way we all talk
about what is our common
history, the way we examine
things, and I think we're still
exploring what these different
points of view mean, and it's a
journey we'll all need to be on,
because we don't have the guide
stone of a, you know, sort of
white, European,  male-dominated
through history.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you very
much.  Does anybody want to jump
in before I, yes?
>> SPEAKER: I think one of the
points I'd make is that all of
us, in some ways, are
beneficiaries of the
technological changes that have
lessened the cost and the, um,
some would say even the skill
level to get into  film-making,
so that it has become much, much
easier to do what, you know, a
film like Eyes on the Prize
today, you could probably do it
for much less money, simply
because the equipment would be
so much less, the editing
equipment, all of that sort of
thing, and I think that looking
forward into the future, what I
see coming out of
African American film-making is
that poliferation is kind of
pulling us, even within the
African American community, now
you have gay film-makers, black
film-makers, might be trying to
explain that experience, you
have so much diversity within
each of these communities that
one thing I fear is that it's
very difficult to get a sense,
you know, right now, for
example, I've been involved in
more than two dozen documentary
films about Black American life,
and most of it 20th century,
and it seems like the pace of
that keeps increasing
, and I think there is that
concern that we're losing a
sense of even the commonality of
being black, much less being
American, and maybe that's good,
because  otherwise, you would
not have a sense that these
communities exist, but in terms
of trying to get a sense of it,
you know, for many of my
students, I teach, in fact, I'll
be teaching next quarter a
course on Black independent
film, and I find that
maybe one student might have
seen some of these fairly famous
films.  Charles Burnette,
people who really made major
contributions, they haven't even
seen early  Spike Lee, so it's,
um, they might have seen
Malcolm X, but that's it.  So, I
think that one of the problems
we're going to have is that
there are audiences, but it's
going to be  smaller and smaller
rather than larger and larger.
>> SPEAKER: So, let me actually
address the changing
marketplace for documentaries,
and I'd love to have any of your
responses.  So, this is a point
at which Netflix is busy giving
people
money, and, um, is launching,
you know, entire lines, you've
got, um, Vice and Vulture doing
instant journalism, Buzzfeed
explainers apparently educating
an entire new generation, and
you've got cable channels just
stuffed with wall-to-wall,
something that looks sort of
like maybe documentary.  Um, and
you have a legacy that's been
built-up largely through the
hard work of public television
that is, that honors the notion
of documentary as, like, a
really authentic true thing.  At
the same time, you have an
enormous proliferation and
leaping into the marketplace of
Netflix, Amazon, and so many
more, so what's the role now of
public television documentary?
You know, surely not the only
game in town.  Um, expensive, oh
my god, compared to, like,
almost any other source for
documentary, and, um, relatively
slow compared to some of the
others.  What's the role?  No
pressure.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: But if you could
provide us the answer.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: It's an enormous
challenge.  One of the great
challenges is going to be, you
know, how do you pick your way
through all of this stuff and
know what's true and what's
trustworthy, and people maybe
won't care about that as much.
There's going to be an enormous
amount of material that's out
there in the world, being
produced in all these different
areas, and, um, it's going to be
manipulated and used, because
this is the most manipulative of
media, and it's going to be, so
we're going to have a harder
and harder time trying to figure
out what we can trust
.
>> SPEAKER: The
trust brand.
>> SPEAKER: The trust brand,
and that goes to very expensive,
um, you know, high octane
documentaries, made with big
budgets for HBO and for, um,
Netflix and others as well.
There are, you know, it's very
easy to put your hand on the
scale, you know, in
documentaries and to be able to
manipulate this medium towards
certain points of view.  There's
nothing easier than to kind of,
um, you know, Michael Moore's
famous film of, you know,
Fahrenheit 911, being able to
sort of get that sequences, it's
not hard to do, it's very easy
to be able to manipulate
archival material and to use it
in different ways, to lay a
voice over it, so we have a deep
worry, I think, behind all of
this as to what lies behind it
and where you have trust.  The
only thing that we can hold on
to is to say we really believe
that you can trust us, and the
way in which you trust us is the
body of work and the way in
which we keep doing it, and
also, to make it as transparent
as possible.  So, we made, for
me, one of the great moments in
the life of  Frontline was 1995,
we'd just done a film on Waco,
the inside story, and, um, we'd
done all these interviews with,
um, major FBI guys who were part
of negotiating with Karesh, we
even had the audio tapes of the
actual negotiations, and I kept
saying can't we make a radio
show, and somebody said, you can
put it on the web.  What's that
?  1995, we built --
>> SPEAKER: That was still
mosaic.
>> SPEAKER: We built a website
for Waco, the inside story, with
that archival material, plus I
said, well, can't we put the
whole film on there?  And they
said, well, you can't do that
yet, and, so, then we put the
interviews up, and all the
interviews for these were, and
that website exists today,
people still actually write to
us about that website, and from
then on, we began publishing all
of the edited, longer versions
of the primary source materials
behind the Frontline, so that
last week, the second film that
ran of Puti n's  Revenge, there
were 65 interviews, a body of
work that's both historically
important, now, that's not going
to persuade the average person
that's doing it that they're
going to go off and hunt through
the interview material, but
you've made it completely
transparent.  In some way, that
seeps deeply into the culture,
that if we raise the bar really
high, and hold to that bar, then
we begin to hold on to who we
are and why we remain the only
place anywhere in the media
culture that does that, and, so,
that's our, um--
>> SPEAKER: Okay, so, that's
your answer.  You want to go,
Margaret?
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. What I just
wanted to say is that you can
take that trust too, and we all
had to learn, um, using new
platforms, and it was
challenging, in many ways,
because we had been so schooled
in the delivery of hour-
hour-long documentaries, or in
the case of American Experience,
six-hour long  documentaries or
four-hour long documentaries,
which were big biographies of
Presidents.  Um, so, we had to
learn how to use the material on
YouTube, and we had to learn
podcasting, and we had to learn
all of the different platforms,
mobile platforms, where we could
deliver the same kind of
context, shorter, but carries
the same branding and the same,
um, scrutiny that goes into an
hour-long documentary and
deliver it to your students, who
are not going to be watching
hour-long documentaries
documentaries, I mean unless
somebody leads them to it and
shows them what the benefits are
and what the range of interest
is.
>> SPEAKER: And we're doing
that.  We're getting millions of
viewers through Facebook.
>> SPEAKER: I think we're
sitting in an archive.  I think
for any documentary, one of the
most important tasks is what do
you do with all the material
that you've brought together,
especially the video material,
and I think one of the most
important decisions for Eyes on
the Prize was to put it in an
archive, where now you can go
and, um, watch the entire
Coretta  King interview or any
other interview done during that
time.
>> SPEAKER: So, we're going to
run out of time.  I want to make
sure we get your answer, Steve,
for the, the answer for trust
has been partly transparency,
but it's also been partly brand.
Trust us, because we are PBS,
we are American Experience, we
are Frontline, and you're
dealing with a different
community, who are, um,
independent film-makers of, um,
in your case, specifically
Asian-American  film-makers, but
each consortia does, in the
series, they showcase their work
, all of this work which is very
, very different, so how do you
address Clay's point about a
sintriffial universe of
information out there?
>> SPEAKER: You know,
historically, our stuff shows up
into the system through a
variety of ways, not through one
particular strand, you know,
one brand, although in recent
times, in fact, we have a
project that's going on American
Experience next May that makes
extensive use of archival
materials, and we're also
participating in the, um,
archives of public broadcasting,
I'm really proud of, but to
speak in general of this, you
know, a hundred titles a year
that collectively come from
independent sources, and we put
our stuff on POV, that many of
you may know about, um, you
know, it is a, I am optimistic
moving into the future, because
this is what we all have to
learn, how to incorporate many
more points of view and many
more voices in public
broadcasting, and if you stay
true to that, and it's
absolutely mission-driven, what
we heard earlier, it is the
future, and then make use of
this incredible education
network.  I'm going to setup the
next panel for you, PBS
learning media, which we, you
know, put our materials on and
make available to teachers, um,
that I feel very confident about
the future of this enterprise,
because there are thousands,
tens of thousands of young
makers who really want to speak
authentic stories, that don't
necessarily have to be in
commercial media and be all
about selling a product, or even
in the best sense, just to
entertain alone.  I think there
are so many issues that we share
in public  broadcasting, if it
stays true to the mission, is
that singular place.
>> SPEAKER: So, we're going to,
um, we've got, like, 3 more
minutes, and I'd like to be able
to use them to talk to the
issue you addressed, which is
archives, and Clay has told us
about, is Eyes on the Prize work
in APB somewhere?
>> SPEAKER: Yes. Same as
always
.
>> SPEAKER: Is D Den
Show?
>> SPEAKER: That's an online
digital archive, and we have
placed a number of our
collections, the collection
where he  interviewed hundreds
and hundreds of veterans, we've
placed all those interviews on
that source, but all of the
other kinds of works, they're
going to go into library of
Congress as part of our
collections.
>> SPEAKER: Fantastic. You?
>> SPEAKER: I would just
recommend seeing the
Putin's Revenge stuff.  It was
done with  Duke, and it's state
of the art technology.  65
interviews, they're all video
interviews, you can both read it
and be able to track the video
at the same time.  You can reach
in and clip a piece out and
share it, and, um, it's the most
interactive, profoundly sort
of, um, impressive archive.
>> SPEAKER: Fantastic. And in
terms of  APB, is there
Frontline material?
>> SPEAKER: I think it's due.
Karen  tells me it's in the
pipeline.
>> SPEAKER: Can I, I just want
to go back a little bit to
something he had said about the
appetite for documentaries.  I
also am on the board of POV, the
independent documentary series,
and I am astonished, every
year, we have an open call, and
we get more than a thousand
entries from independent
producers, and of those, it has
to be called to, like, we've got
18 slots, so that's every
single  year, and even in the,
after the, during the, you know,
in the middle of the year, when
there's no entry date, they get
inundated with phone calls, or
they get tapes or, you know, um,
links to films that have been
produced, so there's something
going on.  It reminds me of the
time when, you know, I was at
CBS, and they announced the
death of the documentary, I
don't think we can say that the
documentary is dying.  I see
quite the opposite.  I see this
hunger in young people, made
possible by technology, in some
cases, and also, just this kind
of, um, incessant, fervent
curiosity that they have about
their world, and they're making
these films for practically
nothing, and some of them are
really terrific.  So, I'm
optimistic.
>> SPEAKER: Um, I interrupted
you, Clay.
>> SPEAKER: Two words that have
not come up and that are really
central in this is intellectual
property, and I think that, in
general, scholarship and
documentary film- film-makers
have not been aggressive enough
in using fair use.  I think that
in part, that comes from when,
a particular film that I was
involved in, when it came to
being shown on  PBS, PBS
required certain kinds of
coverage, you know, for obvious
reasons, legal reasons, and that
forced them to go back, and in
this case, you know, have to
take out, um, things, so I think
at every level, intellectual
property issues have been
crucial.  Not so much in terms
of cost, but just uncertainty
about use.
>> SPEAKER: And people all
being on the same page about
what they regard as acceptable,
which is where the best
practices have been somewhat
helpful.  All right, last
comments?  Because we have,
like, 15 seconds left.  Go.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Your 15 seconds?
>> SPEAKER: Thank you.
>> SPEAKER: I thank you. Yes.
Thank  you.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you,
everybody.  Our next panel is
going to begin.  We're going to
show some clips, which I hope
you'll stay
seated this time to watch.  Um,
it's on educational uses of
public broadcasting, and it will
begin, the panel will begin at
5:10, but we're going to start
clips right now.  And will the
panelists please come and get
mic
'd?  Thank you.
>> SPEAKER: So, our moderator
for our next panel on the
educational uses of public
broadcasting is the person who
during most of my tenure as the
head of WGBH held the purse
strings, first at PBS and then
at CBB, because she had the most
important programming jobs in
those two institutions, not
simultaneously, I would say.
Jennifer Lawson was the
Executive Vice President of
programming and commercial
services at PBS, and then was
Senior Vice President for
television and digital content
at CBP, and during a little bit
of time between those two, she
ran the Howard University public
station, WHUT.  Jennifer has
received numerous awards and
honors for her work in public
media.  The Hollywood Reporter
named her, at one point, one of
the 50 most influential women in
entertainment in the world.
So, Jennifer, take it away.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Thank you very
much.  Education is a
fundamental element of public
broadcasting.  Public television
was  established as educational
television first in many places
around the country, the E in
the call letters of many
stations, like WETA, or  KCET in
Los Angeles
, references education, and
several of the 362 public
television stations are licensed
to universities, such as the
one Henry just mentioned, W WGBH
at Howard  University, or
Arizona PBS, which originated at
Arizona State University.
Public
television, together with
public non-commercial radio,
combined to serve as the most
consistent and significant place
for informal learning for
listeners and viewers of all
ages.  We'll discuss public
broadcasting's educational
underpinnings, its legacy, and
how the preservation of this
content creates future
opportunities.  I have the
privilege now of introducing our
distinguished panel, and we
have here Paula
Apsell, who is director of the
WGBH science unit.  Nova has won
every major broadcasting award,
including the Emmy, the
Peabody, the AAAS Science
Journalism Award, and the DuPont
Columbia Gold Baton, as well as
an academy award nomination.
She has also been recognized
with numerous personal awards
.  Nova is a favorite of
teachers who make extensive use
of its high-quality educational
materials and its website, with
popular short videos and thought
leader columns as one of the
most  popular on PBS.org.  Lloyd
Morrisett, Lloyd is a
co-creator of Sesame Street and
a  co-founder of Sesame Workshop
, which produces  Sesame Street.
He was board chair of the
workshop for 30 years and is now
a trustee and chairman emeritus
.  He is also an experimental
psychology scholar, a former
Vice President of the Carnegie
Corporation and the Carnegie
Foundation for the advancement
of teaching.  He was President
of the John and Mary Markell
Foundation from
foundation.  He is currently a
trustee of  Public Agenda, a
non-profit organization
conducting research to inform
public policy issues.  Kathryn
Ostrofsky teaches in the
Department of History at Angelou
State  University in San
Angelou, Texas.  Kathryn's areas
of research and teaching
include 20th century U.S.
cultural history, sound studies,
television studies, the history
of race and ethnicity, and the
history of media and
communications.  She is also
working to preserve audio,
visual, and paper archival
sources related to children's
television.  She has a doctorate
in history from the University
of Pennsylvania, and her oral
history of the the 1970s through
the sounds of Sesame Street has
led to numerous speaking
engagements and conference
presentations.  She is under
contract with the University of
California  Press for a book on
this topic.  I'd like to start
with Lloyd Morrisett and to talk
a bit about the origins of
Sesame Street, and I know that
you were at the Carnegie
Foundation and had a very good
overview of the state of
education in America at that
time, and I would just, I think
it would be really useful if you
would put Sesame Street in
that, in the context of those
times and tell us a little bit
about what led to its creation.
>> SPEAKER: Well, those of you
who are expecting
Elmo, I'm not Elmo.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I think, to talk
about the origins of Sesame
Street, you have to re-create in
your minds the events of that
decade, and I'm going to list
them here, and I'm going to read
the list, because I don't want
to leave anything out.  1960,
television may have given
Senator John F. Kennedy the edge
he needed to defeat Vice
President Nixon in the first
televised presidential debate.
Kennedy wins the election by a
margin of 113,000 votes out of
69 million votes cast.  1961,
FCC chairman makes his famous
speech, declaring that
television is a vast wasteland.
1962, 90 percent of Americans
own a television set.  ABC
begins broadcasting in color.
The federal government funds
public broadcasting through the
Education Television Facilities
Act.  June of
1962, President Kennedy
federalizes Alabama's National
Guard and orders  Governor
George Wallace to allow two
black students to be enrolled at
the university
.  Just recounting these events,
I find I'm very emotional.  In
January of
1962, Martin Luther King
delivers his I Have A Dream
speech.  In August, more than
200,000 Americans march on
Washington in support of civil
rights.
1964, the 24th Amendment to
the Constitution makes U.S. poll
taxes unconstitutional.  March
1964, President Johnson declares
a war on poverty.  He signs an
Economic Opportunity Act in
August.  Again, in 1964,
President Johnson signs the bill
enacting Medicare.  The great
society is underway.  In August
of
1964, Congress approves the
resolution authorizing President
Johnson to take all necessary
majors to repel any armed attack
against forces of the United
States and to prevent further
aggression.  December of of
1964, President
Johnson announces a substantial
increase
in -- inaudible --
in
in 1965, January, in a state of
the union message, President
Johnson outlines the program for
the great society that will
eliminate  poverty in America.
In February, Dr. Martin Luther
King is arrested in Selma,
Alabama
.  In February, also, Malcolm X
is assassinated
coincidentally during national
brotherhood  week.  June of
1965, Congress authorizes the
use of ground troops in Vietnam,
.  A complete ground defense is
underway, and the column will
collapse in a few weeks weeks
weeks.  Not months, but
weeks.  125,000 troops are in
Vietnam.  In August that year,
the Voting Rights Act becomes
law, and in August of that year,
the Carnegie  Commission on
educational television begins
its landmark study of broadcast.
In 1967, public broadcasting
laboratory airs over national
educational television.  It is a
Sunday night magazine program
designed to showcase the
relevance and importance of
public television.  We'll come
back to that, because that was
much more important historically
in public  broadcasting than is
generally recognized.  In March
of 1968, President Johnson
announces that he will not
accept the nomination for
another term.  His presidency
has become another  casualty of
Vietnam War.  In 1968 in April,
Martin Luther King is
assassinated
.  In
1969 -- inaudible -- begins,
five nights a week.  In November
of that year, Sesame Street
goes on the air
.  Now, as you can tell from my
emotions, this was a very
turbulent time
.  It strongly affected all of
us, all of us who were alive
then, and it was out of that in
part that Sesame Street was born
.  We started working on the
idea in
1966, and the people that came
to us to help, our Executive
Vice President, for example,
Joan Kuney obviously joined me
in the original idea, all of us
were very affected by the events
I've discussed, and so Sesame
Street was in part born out of a
belief in civil rights that we
all had
.  The fact that it appeared on
public television was somewhat
of an accident.  When we first
started to raise money for it in
1966, Doc Hal had become
commissioner of education, and
he had been  formally
superintendent of schools in
scarsdale, and he was one of the
first people we talked to about
it.  He, after some
deliberation, overruled his
staff and said that he would
find
$4 million to help us get on
the air.  So, with that $4
million, plus the million
dollars that Carnegie had
already
put up, we had
$5 million.  Lou Halesman, who
was  Doc Hal's point person in
, Lou came out of NBC
television, and he strongly
believed that the program should
be on commercial television.
He said where are the people
going?  They're on commercial
television, that's where you
have to be.  So, we took that
advice seriously, and I met
with, um, NBC, CBS, Group W
Broadcasting, and got very nice,
um, a very nice reception, but
no money, no airtime.  The
program was  fully funded, but
we couldn't understand, I
couldn't understand, in my
naivety, why, with a fully
funded program, we couldn't have
any  airtime.  Later, I
realized, and I've realized it
ever since, that the advertising
part wasn't interested in
having those minutes sold that
way.  They wanted to raise money
around the program, and they
couldn't, so the commercial
broadcasters turned us down, and
just at that point, the Public
Broadcasting Act had been
signed, and public broadcasting
needed programming, we needed
airtime, it was a, I won't say
it was made in heaven, but it
was certainly made by an
accident of history.  So, the
things that made it
possible, in addition to the
one that I've already cited, are
that the people, essentially,
who created the climate to
accept the idea of a children's
television program were all in
their place.  John Gardener had
been my boss at Carnegie, was a
good friend.  Doc Hal had also
become a friend.  Other people
who were not directly, um,
involved in the origins, but
created the climate in
Washington that made it possible
, he's been a friend the rest of
his life for me.  Henry Gellar,
who some of you may remember
was an ardent fan of the
public's use of  broadcasting
and not giving it away free to
commercial broadcasters.  The
other person I'd mention, whose
name has already come up, is
Doug Cater.  Doug Cater was
Lyndon Johnson's special
assistant for education.  He
shepherded the Public
Broadcasting Act through the
process of getting it to
Congress, and he was also a
great friend of the kinds of
things that we were trying to do
.  Joan Kuney had been at NBC,
and then she had been at Channel
13, where she was a commercial,
not a commercial, a
documentary producer and had
three good documentaries to her
name.  So, essentially, not only
had the climate of opinion in
the country been, um,
fertilized, I'll say, by the
events of the 19 60s, but the
particular people I've mentioned
were all interested in the
public's use of public
facilities and public education.
They are what made the idea
become possible.  I think I'll
stop there, Jennifer.
>> SPEAKER: Terrific. Thank
you.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Paula, your work
exemplifies informal education.
You've helped popularize and
demystify science and science
education, and you've given
exposure to some scientists that
has made them as popular as
rockstars
.  It's easy to go places, and
people go, oh, wow,  Brian
Green, string theory, you know,
and, so, it's, um, and then
you've also shown us women and
people of color in the sciences
routinely throughout your series
.  With Nova, what's the origin,
how did we get from there to
here?
>> SPEAKER: That's good. First
of all, I just want to say, I'm
just awed to be sitting next to
Lloyd, because my daughter,
Natalie, is here with me today,
and I just can see in my mind's
eye, and this makes me
emotional, when she and her
sisters would be sitting on that
couch every single day at 4:00
o'clock, their thumbs in their
mouth, a bomb could have gone
off in that room, and they would
not have  moved, and what they
learned from Sesame  Street, way
beyond the importance of the
letters, the lessons about life,
about ethics, about morality,
about how you treat other people
of all different kinds, even if
they're not familiar to you,
and now, as everyone  knows, I
have a grandson, and he watches
The  Science Kid and also Sesame
Street and the other programs
on PBS, so as well as being a
content-generator, I'm a
recipient of all the good things
that PBS does for kids and
educationally, and it's just,
really, it's just overwhelming.
I feel so fortunate to be apart
of this.  Now, on to Nova.  So,
education is in  Nova's DNA.
We've been producing content for
teachers and students for as
long as we've been on PBS, and
that's 44 years, which is kind
of an eternity in television,
and now I have to mention
another man that I think is a
really great person, and that is
Michael Ambersino, who started
Nova, and Michael just had --
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Michael just had a
really good idea.  Very simple.
His idea was science is not a
collection of facts, it's a
story, and if you tell the story
right, with characters and with
visuals, then people will
watch, and they will learn, but
they will enjoy, and it will
change their opinion about
science and make, help them to
understand what an important
part of our lives and what an
important, I would say cultural
institution, that it is really a
thrill to get a better
understanding of our world, and
Michael always knew that, um,
that it was very important for
Nova to go out to teachers as
well, and that they should have
supplementary materials that
would help them use Nova in the
classroom.  So, for years and
years and years, we made
teachers' plans, which had all
sorts of suggestions and tips
and activities for the classroom
, but teaching changes,
education changes, and
technology changes
, and now, it began as teacher's
domain at WGBH, went to PBS as
learning media, a   fabulous
digital library, the central hub
for all the educational content
produced by all the PBS brands,
and it now reaches more than 2
million educators, which is
amazing, and WGBH is the stem
lead for PBSLM, and Nova itself
has contributed more than 900
resources, mainly video clips,
lots of animation, and these are
all contextualized with, um,
teaching standards and
discussion questions and
background essays, and we
promote these, um, clips really
rigorously to teachers at
conferences.  We also create new
digital content, like Nova Labs
, which is a platform of science
games and interactives that
uses real scientific data, and
these are actually, they were
originally designed for teens to
use at home and, you  know, not
as an in-school activity, but
they turned out to be really
popular with teachers, which,
um, which use them all the time
and actually assign them to
their students to do as
homework.  So, to date, that
platform has engaged nearly more
than 4 million unique  viewers,
and our education lab, and I
just find this amazing, is Nova
's most visited page, so I find
that amazing.  We have an
upcoming  two-hour program on
black holes, which is  hosted by
astrophysicist, Jana Levin, and
to go with that, we create an
iPad app that allows players to
navigate the
cosmos by hurling stars at
various sulest real objects.
That's what we call our our
educational content, whether
formal or informal, but science
is for everyone, and so is Nova,
and, so, of course, I love it
when people tell me I went into
science or  engineering as a
result of watching Nova, but
really, we want to stoke
curiosity and excitement about
science in people of all ages.
So, we have a very rich historic
archive that chronicles
scientific research over four
decades.  If you want to know
the origins of genetic
engineering or
how artificial intelligence got
started, we've been covering
that throughout the 20th century
and now  the 21st century on
Nova, and at any given time, we
have about a hundred full-length
programs available to everyone
to watch online on PBS.org for
free.  We also reach out into
the community.  We've created a
coalition of science, um, cafes,
more than 400 of them, and we
ourselves, every month at WGBH's
studio at the Boston Public
Library, we hold a science cafe
for anyone who wants to come,
and these science cafes are
usually held at, um,
non-traditional settings.
They're a chance for people to
actually interact with real
scientists, and it's really kind
of amazing to know how many
people in their daily life don't
get a chance to really meet a
scientist and talk to them, and
I think that's why people get
very wrong ideas about
scientists and about science,
and, so, and people really enjoy
these settings when they're
held, and an example of this is
we also, of our reaching out
into the community is our
program, School of the Future,
which actually looked at the
issue of the
educational equity and what
kinds of new techniques and
technologies can be used to help
equalize things.  We organized
293 community screenings at K12
settings, at community
organizations, and really, all
over the place, and people came,
and they really engaged in the
discussion of how education can
be made better for everyone.
And finally, and this really
touches the point that you made,
Jennifer, we want people from
all backgrounds to appreciate
the importance of science in our
lives and the crucial role that
science literacy plays in a
democracy.  And now, CPB, with
their help, we've been able to
develop short-form video that
explains the science behind many
of the stories that are
dominating the news cycle.  If
you, um, and embedded on all of
our work is the mandate that we
have in public media, to reflect
the diversity of all people and
experiences in our country.  We
are a hundred percent committed
to increasing diversity in
front of and behind the camera,
by actively cultivating both
producers and scientists of
color, and I really invite you
to take a look at any current
Nova, and you'll be able to see
what we're doing, but equally
important to  that, we're
actually expanding the scope of
the stories we tell, focusing
more on the ways that science
impacts social justice.  In our
episode last spring, poise
poison water, about the Flint,
Michigan water crisis is an
example of that, with all its
associated content, and I also
believe that this really
illustrates the importance of
education being embedded in a
production unit like Nova.  Our
education director, Ralph Bukae,
who taught biology in an inner
city high school in Philadelphia
and can really share that
experience with all of us, he
has a leadership role in our
unit, and not only does this
integration drive many of our
initiatives, but the lessons
that we
learn in educational and
digital and broadcast go back
and forth, and they are all
enriched by this integration,
and that helps us better to
serve the American people.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Kathryn, you've
studied children's television
and Sesame Street in real depth,
and you've learned a lot about
the role of the series and
educating preschoolers, but
through your work and through
the particular angles that you
have approached Sesame Street,
you've learned a lot about our
society as well, and could you
share some of your observations
with us?
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. I think I'm
here to represent the generation
that did grow up on  PBS.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: And, um, and my
education, of course, started
with Sesame Street and is
continuing with Sesame Street
through my graduate school, and
now in my teaching.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: I just never
stopped watching it.  Um, so,
I've been asked to talk about
public broadcasting as history,
and that's why I use Sesame
Street as a historical source,
but so much of public
broadcasting, of course, can be
used as historical sources, and
the way that we often think
about that is that public
broadcasting recorded our past,
um, the public affairs shows,
the talk shows, recordings of
great performances, um, are now
an archive of our history, and
that is true, but as a scholar
and as a teacher, I am more
interested in  thinking about
the ways that public
broadcasting our history because
it is a forum, a vehicle, a
tool through which we seek to
understand our past and our
present and shape our future.  I
think this is a theme that's
been running throughout all the
panels this afternoon, the theme
of democatization and
interactivity, so this happens,
um, from both angles, from the
producers, as well as from the
audiences.  From the producers,
the way that they approach their
programs, they don't just
report the news, they analyze
it, they don't just ask boiler
plate questions of celebrities,
they engage them in a
conversation that can take
any turn, even, um, almost
coming to physical blows.  Um,
Lloyd Morrisett did not just use
television to teach letters and
numbers, they designed a
program that reflected
flected -- they built the
program to be able to evolve and
to, um, be responsive to
society's changing educational
needs and cultural needs.  So,
all of these programs, they're
not just series of short
conversations or presentations,
rather they are decades-long
conversations between producers
and audiences about issues that
matter to us.  So, public
broadcasting creates, in
particular creates a really rich
record of these discussions of
these long conversations,
because its funding comes from
the government and philanthropic
foundations, um, and viewers
like you --
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Producers and
stations constantly have to
articulate to their  audiences
and to their funders what
they're doing, why they're doing
it like that, and what impact
it's having.  This creates a
paper trail that is amazing for
historians.  Um, because public
broadcasting is for the people
and, um, it's mobilizing this
technology, not for advertisers,
but for the audiences
themselves, educators, social
activists, have, through the
years, felt that they could and
should make their voices heard
in public media as a
collaborative effort to improve
programs or to use public
broadcasting as a tool for
broader social change.  So, they
do talk back to their
televisions, as Nicholas
Johnson suggested, suggested.
So, in the case of Sesame
Street, the producers and the
audiences agreed that the show
should provide models for ideal
community  interactions, but as
Lloyd was just talking about,
there's a lot going on in the
60s and the 70s.  There's civil
rights, cultural pride
movements, proliferating and
fragmenting in the 1970s, so all
of these people who are
invested in Sesame Street in
some way don't agree on what
that ideal community should look
like or sound like, how those
people should behave.  So, cast
members, staff, parents,
critics, advocacy groups, like
the National  Organization Group
of Women had ongoing
discussions about how characters
should speak, what musical
guests to feature, how to
represent and celebrate
diversity without perpetuating
stereotypes, and there was no
easy answers, and luckily,
Sesame Street is a variety show,
so they could sort of do,
experiment with all these things
at the same time and see what
worked.  So, but this
engagement with social issues
also happens long after the
program's first air, and it's,
it has become cliche to say that
documentaries bring the past to
life, but they certainly do in
my classroom, not just
metaphorically, but, um, these
programs often have the power to
continue the traditions that
they discuss.  The first episode
of Eyes on the Prize, for
example, it's called Awakenings,
and it shows how media
coverage of the lynchings, um,
lynching of Emmett Till and the
sham trial that allowed his
murderers to go free led to a,
um, public consciousness about
the conditions of Jim Crow and
it inspired Civil Rights
actions.  Watching the
documentary itself is a
consciousness-raising experience
for my students, and there's no
more powerful demonstration for
why so many people risked their
lives for Civil Rights.  One
episode of the American
Experience series on Latino
Americans covers the 1968
walk-outs through which the high
school students took control of
their education and sought to
understand their place, the
place of themselves in their
families in American history and
American society, and for one
of my students a couple of years
ago, she had heard about the
walk-outs from her mother who
had participated in them, but to
see, um, those events depicted
on  national television, in a
U.S. history survey class, um,
did the same thing for her, it
inspired her to take her own
education into her own hands
and, um, figure out her place in
society.  So, um, public
television, we're here talking
about preservation, public
television and radio need to be
preserved, not just because they
have recorded our history,
because they continue to be the
material that we use every day
to engage with our past or our
future, shape our future.
>> SPEAKER: Absolutely.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: I think your
comments underscore what has
been said too at some of the
other panels about the
incredible importance of the
material, not just during the
time that it is broadcast, but
its archival  value into the
future.  Um, before we come back
to preservation, I'd like to go
back to Lloyd for a quick
question that relates to your
background in psychology too,
and that is that, um, for
example, a national study
recently revealed that 50
percent of American children
under the age of 18 have
experienced a  traumatic event,
such as witnessing violent acts
or experiencing natural
disasters.  Last month, Sesame
Street, Sesame Workshop launched
an initiative to help children
cope with these traumatic
experiences, and Sesame Street
puppets have often in the past
been used to help children talk
about events, like a death in
the family or divorce, and when
you and Joan were starting
Sesame, did you envision this
kind of therapeutic role for the
series in its early days, or
did that, is that something that
evolved?
>> SPEAKER: It evolved. The
early days, the question we were
tasked with answering, can
television teach anything?  We
had to answer that with a
positive in order to gain more
funding.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: So, that was the
hard work of it.  So, initially,
we concentrated on thing
things that were taught in
school, or needed to be taught
in school, letters, numbers, so
on, and could it be easily
measured.  Those were the things
we were really trying to look
at, and fortunately, the study
that came out showed that people
that watched more, learned
more.  With that started, with
the confidence that we were
going to be able to continue,
once we got a second season's
funding, we then began to
broaden the curriculum to take
into account some of the things
that you're talking about,
although the, um, the real
change probably came much later.
The military families project
was probably the most important
change in that regard, and now,
of course, as you mentioned,
traumatic events
, autism would be another
example, where we would not have
been able to do that initially,
but as the program evolved, we
have been able to do more of it.
>> SPEAKER: All right.
>> SPEAKER: I'd like to address
that issue.
>> SPEAKER: Please.
>> SPEAKER: Of can television
teach anything, because I think
it's really an important
question, and it's very
important for  Nova, in a way,
because part of our, you know,
we were, you know, 40 years
ago, and we're still discussing
it, is is our primary function
to educate or to entertain, and
we're always kind of talking
about how you blend those two
things, but when you think back
to your own science classes and
how the teacher was always
talking about things that you
couldn't understand what he or
she was talking about, because
you couldn't visualize it, you
had absolutely no frame of
reference for it, and I think
it's one of the huge values to
PBS  Learning Media and to their
huge stem collection, because
it helps, it provides visuals,
so when you're talking about a
volcano and what's going on, the
molten magnum under the Earth,
who really knows what that means
when you're a kid?  But here,
you can have an animation, and
it can be contextualized by your
teacher, because there are, you
know, the archive helps.  So, I
really, I just think, in terms
of science, visuals are just so
important, and they also help
both kids and everyone take the
world from another  perspective.
They're designed to show you
things that you can't see for
yourself, and that, in a way,
expands your world, and that, to
me, is just really one of the
benefits of the educational uses
of our material and of the fact
that we are fortunate enough to
be able to produce these things
and have the resources to do
so, even though it's always a
struggle in the first place.
>> SPEAKER: And you've had, in
many  cases, the nature of your
funding from places like the
National Science Foundation, or
the funding that you've received
or Sesame Workshop has received
has required rigorous
evaluation, right, and testing
as part of the proving that it
has this educational benefit.
>> SPEAKER: Oh, rigorous
evaluation.
>> SPEAKER: And costly.
>> SPEAKER: But it's not, you
know, now, one thing that the
National Science Foundation, and
actually, a lot of other
funders are going off to is they
want you to use your material
not just to evaluate it, to see
if it's any good, but they
wanted they want it to add to
the body of learning of how
people learn from the visual
media, whether they get more out
of an  hour-long documentary,
whether they get more out of
short-form video, what the
difference  is, what the
difference is in their attitudes
towards science, so we're
really accumulating with some of
our projects, and we're working
with academics on this, because
we're not, I mean, I'm a TV
producer, trust me, I couldn't
begin to figure out how to do
these projects, but to use them
to really understand the
fundamentals of science
learning, and it's very
gratifying that our material can
be used for that.
>> SPEAKER: Right. Kathryn,
you had mentioned to me a little
earlier that in addition to the
audio visual materials being so
incredibly important, that
there are other resources, like
the kind that Paula just
mentioned, or the notes from the
creation of a program work that
producers do that they might
just think is a real throw-away,
that some of that has archival
value for scholars like you.
>> SPEAKER: Yes. I've been
using, um,
the Sesame Street's research
notes too.  I'm struck by the
parallels between the studies
and the outreach that Nova and
Sesame Street have had.  They're
also a paper trail for learning
about how we learn from media,
learning about what, um, the
history of the discipline of
psychology or education or
whoever's doing these studies,
um, is
, and they're also fun for me to
look at from a humanities
perspective, because you do have
certain things that you're
testing for your show, but that
doesn't mean that's all we can
learn from that data.  So, I go
in and read it from a
historian's point of view and
find completely different
information about, for instance,
cultural differences between
the Spanish-speaking and English
English-speaking kids, about
how they're responding to music,
which is not what was being
tested, it was how they were
learning the Spanish language,
but there's more information
there than is used in your
studies.  So, your studies have
broader impact beyond what
you're doing with them.
>> SPEAKER: And as we talk
about these
, preserving content and
material from public media and
these documents, I also want to
mention that we probably haven't
represented fully enough the
broadest range of public  media,
because there's also culture
and the arts, and there is so
much, I think, in terms of
performance program, cultural
programs that are created by
producers, both at the national
and local level, and so I also
want to bring that into the
discussion, as well as, um,
public media creating a really,
really robust archive of local
content.  Most public media
stations and public radio really
do an incredible amount at the
local level, and so there's a
wealth of material and a history
of communities that's being
created there as well.  Now, we
have talked, though, about
reaching the youngest viewers,
and we've also talked about
adults, in many ways, although I
must say that you're going far
beyond adults, when I look at
slimy, gross science programs
that Nova is apart of.
>> SPEAKER: Gross science.
>> SPEAKER: Yes, gross science.
>> SPEAKER: Call it what it is.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah, or some of
your other programs that are,
you know, what makes you vomit,
you know.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: It's your body,
you've got to understand it.
>> SPEAKER: Yeah. So, I could
imagine you attracting a much
broader age range, but that has
been one of the challenges, I
think, that has plagued public
media for a number of years, and
I want to start with you,
Lloyd, and just going back to
the question of did Sesame
Workshop, as the children's
television  workshop, what
efforts were made in the sort of
earlier years in trying to go
beyond  preschoolers and to
reach the pre-teens and
teenagers?
>> SPEAKER: Well, as Paula has
mentioned, in producing a
television show, you have to
attract the audience, as well as
teach them something, and, so,
Sesame Street was designed in
the beginning, I need to start
that again.  The viewing
conditions in 1969 are extremely
different than they are today.
In 1969, typically, families
had one television set, the
family watched together, and the
parents could act as an
intermediary between what was on
the television set and what the
child learned, say, Johnny, did
you see that A?  Or Johnny,
take a look at what's coming up
next, it's going to be like, and
that gets Johnny's attention to
something on the set that you
want to teach about
.  Now, I think I saw that
maybe 90 percent of adolescents
and above have smart phones,
television sets are numerous,
and often, the child, at
whatever age, 2 or 3 even,
controls the set himself or
herself
, so the problem of maintaining
an audience and know what
audience you're really trying to
reach is much harder.  I don't
think we've figured it out yet,
but we certainly had the idea
from the beginning that the
adults had to be attracted to
the program as well as their
children.
>> SPEAKER: I used to, like I
said, 4:00 o'clock, I was pretty
tired, sit there, and we'd
watch Sesame Street.  It
appealed to adults as well.  I
mean, I felt like there were two
levels that it was operating on
.
>> SPEAKER: There were. There
was a very important precursor
to what we did.  We used a lot
of the laugh-in techniques in
the early shows.
>> SPEAKER: And I think it very
definitely did, one piece that
I remember, I think it was
Patty Label singing I love my X,
I miss my X, and there's, of
course, the letter X on the
screen, but the look in her eyes
suggested otherwise.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: So, it seemed as if
it was very consciously
designed to --
>> SPEAKER: It was.
>> SPEAKER: To work for both
levels.
>> SPEAKER: And the writers
particularly enjoyed doing that.
They liked to write
one-liners, and kids didn't get
it, but the adults did.
>> SPEAKER: But in terms of the
ages,  yes, I mean, we all
worry in public media about an
aging audience.  I mean, it's,
like,  discussed constantly, and
we sweat it  constantly.  We
try to really figure it out, how
we can appeal to younger
people.  Well, one thing we find
is that we have a very
different audience online, that
the audience online is much
younger, and, so, the idea is
that the audience online, we do
know that they love to watch our
shows on their computer, they
love short-form video, I guess
that's the whole thing about the
attention span, I don't know,
but, um, they also like to watch
our short-form videos, and if
we take them off, oh, our
lawyers are right there, but I
have to say, in two minutes,
they're pirated and put on
YouTube, and you take them down,
and they go back up.  It is
really amazing.  So, I think
this is a key to us; young
people we know do not have
televisions, they don't watch
television that much, they watch
on their  phone, they watch on
their computer.  The hope is
they will, youngsters do grow
up, and very often, they have
families, and their life
changes, and it starts to, um,
they start to realize the value
of public media, and they start
to join their local station, and
I think that there is, maybe
I'm just an optimist, but I
think that, I think if we can
keep reaching out to them and
hold them close to us by various
different forms of what we do,
we will migrate them in a
direction that many of them will
be watching our programs.
Maybe that's just optimistic.
>> SPEAKER: I think there's an
untapped potential for that
middle audience between children
and adults.  Um, certainly, my
students, they're adults, but
they, um, one of the things that
I try to do with the document
documentaries is, that I show in
class is to not just show a
documentary, but do something
with it, and there are a few
documentaries that tell us
something about the historical
profession.  My freshmen are
watching A  Midwife's Tale, but,
um,
you can use these documentaries
to teach about narrative
structure, since they use
narrative structure, we just
heard, you can teach them about
media literacy, which I think
is, um, a really important skill
that they are not coming to
college with these days, and we
need it more than ever.  Um, so,
there are creative ways to use
these programs beyond simply the
formal education or informal
education that they were
designed for
.
>> SPEAKER: Jennifer, you
haven't said anything about it,
but the title, preserving public
media, has two meanings
.  It means archivaly, it also
means continuing it, and we do
not
have Newt at the FCC, we do not
have John Gardener, and I would
think there should be a
considerable amount of concern
about the enduring
health under the current
offices of public media.
>> SPEAKER: Well, I thought
that it was really quite
heartening to hear, with some of
the earlier panels who
addressed that, I thought it was
really quite heartening to hear
their level of optimism about
public broadcasting and its
future and its potential in that
way, but I welcome your
thoughts about this.
>> SPEAKER: Well, I think, I
was going to say one thing, that
I think, you know, we just
talked a minute or so about age.
I mean, the hope is that the
American public will demand the
preservation of public media.
You know, we have to have our
fans out there, they are our
biggest asset, and I think many
of you in this room will
remember, um, under a few years
ago, decades ago, I don't even
remember when it was, in the
90s, when public media was
really  threatened, and people
wrote letters, millions of
letters, and said, no,
absolutely not, you cannot take
this away from us.  That is our
preservation, that is our
guarantee.  So, the concern I
have is, yes, indeed, we want to
expand and get younger people,
listen, I love my older viewers,
keep watching.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: Oldies, but
goodies.  I love you, okay?
Don't stop watching.  People are
living longer and longer, so
it's great.  We do want to get
younger people, but we also want
to get, and I know this is near
and dear to your heart, we want
to get more diversity, not just
because we're ethical people,
but also because that is our
survival.  The American
demographic is changing, and we
have to change with it, and my
job is to really find ways to
and choose  topics that show
people science belongs to you,
not just to me, not, listen,
science has been white, we all
know that.  It's changing, it's
bringing many more minorities
into it.  We used to tear our
hair out to try to find minority
scientists to put on the
screen.  Now, it's really, you
know, in some fields, it's
challenging, but in many, it's
really not hard at all.  That's
great.  So, one way is to really
make sure that we have
scientists of all different
colors and all different
backgrounds on the screen.
Another way is in the choice of
topics, that we have to choose
topics that take into account
people's concerns, and, so,
hopefully, this is not something
that's going to be
accomplished.  We're not going
to expand our percentage of
minorities from 9  or 10 percent
to 25 percent overnight, but my
hope is that if we do it right,
we tell good stories, we're
much more inclusive in topic
choice and people, that people
will respond by watching.  You
know, when we took our show,
poison water to Flint, and we
showed it in  Flint, and, you
know, that community, it was,
the reaction was just so amazing
, that this group of people,
these people were citizen
scientists, they did not wait
and rely on scientists to come
in and do it for them, they
figured out more than the
scientists in a lot of that
agencies what was going wrong
with their pipes, and then to
see themselves  reflected in a
documentary, how they had taken
a role in their own survival and
the survival of their children,
I think they were really amazed
, and I think it gave them a
different feeling about public
media, that it became theirs,
and, you know, it's not easy,
there are not zillions of topics
that you can do it with, but I
think it's imperative.
>> SPEAKER: I want to come back
to  Lloyd's, you know, really
appropriate question about
preserving public media for the
future, but before I do that, I
want to just also get your
thoughts, you know, we have just
a quick minute, I want to get
your thoughts about, um, beyond
the screen, because we've talked
about public broadcasting, and
we're talking about
broadcasting, and I know that
all of you are aware of public
media, and you do your work on
so many other platforms as well,
and I just would welcome your
speaking about the importance of
public media on those
additional platforms.  I think
that you've spoken to that, you
know, in a very articulate way,
Paula, about what Nova has been
doing, but other thoughts about
beyond broadcast?
>> SPEAKER: Well, we get, we
now get an enormous number of
hits on YouTube, where we've
provided a lot of clips, so
that's a reuse of something
that's been done before, but
it's a very useful one.
>> SPEAKER: Um, thoughtful
curation of the things that are
available really helps the
professors that are at most
colleges and universities that
have a lot of students and not a
lot of time to prepare outside
of their fields in teaching, so
I would say, yeah, it's
extremely important.
>> SPEAKER: So so
, like, with PBS Learning
Media, where there's already the
thought given to what age
group, what level, what the
topic is, all of these --
>> SPEAKER: If there are any --
>> SPEAKER: Nicely tagged and
everything.
>> SPEAKER: Yes, properly
tagged, and if there are --
>> SPEAKER: Keywords.
>> SPEAKER: If there are any
interactive things that can go
along with, um, there used to be
an interactive game of
pretending you were in the Gold
Rush and taking on a character
and seeing if you survived, and
it took about two minutes to
play, and it went along with the
documentary for the Gold Rush.
I can't find it anymore.  I
hope it's there.  It may have
moved, or it may have just been
old, and  that's, of course, a
problem.
>> SPEAKER: You have to ask a
10-year-old to find it for you.
They won't have any problem at
all.
>> SPEAKER: So, as a final
question, just to come back to
this all-important point, we're
at the end of this wonderful day
and all of these really very,
very rich panels, um, what about
preserving public media for the
future?
>> SPEAKER: I would worry most
about just not having the budget
go up.  Costs are going up for
everything else, there are a lot
of things that the budget can
be used for, and we just keep it
the same.  So, it's a, in my
view, the strategy is slow
starvation.
>> SPEAKER: I don't want to
starve.
(Laughing.)
>> SPEAKER: As I always say,
I'm on the spending side, and I
like that side, but here is what
I worry about, and you just
mentioned something I think is
very important, which is the
non-broadcast aspect of series
like the ones that we do, and I
know my, um, documentary friends
from the previous panel will
really appreciate.  When we
started our website  in 1996, we
just figured, okay, we'll just
take the same stuff, and we'll
put it online, and maybe we'll,
you know, put a few, you know,
it felt like it was just going
to be a free addition to Nova.
Now, it's its own mouth to feed,
and it's getting to be a
gigantic mouth, and, um, so, the
question is, and it's so
important, because it is a way
to attract so many people who
are not going to turn on the
television set, and I think, we
certainly find it's much harder
to raise money for digital than
it is to raise money for
broadcast.  So, I think that's
something we really have to
figure out and figure out with
the foundations and the other
funders that have supported
public media in the past,
because this is the new world.
This is it.
>> SPEAKER: Kathryn?
>> SPEAKER: Um, oftentimes,
academics and broadcasters and
archivists live in different
worlds, so I think we need more
events like this to bring all of
us together, and that's the
first step, conversations like
the one we've had today.
>> SPEAKER: Thank you.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: We have one more
element to this panel.  We're
going to let Newt Minno have the
last word, but before we do,
first of all, my thanks to all
of you, and to you, Jennifer,
for the work on this panel.  I
hope you have found this
afternoon as fascinating as I
have, being with these founders
of public media and creators of
some of the most iconic and
important content in public
media, and I'd be remiss if I
didn't take us back at the very
end to the other meaning of the
word preserve and to talk, just
a say a few words about the
American Archive of Public
Broadcasting, although I can't
be quite as articulate as
Kathryn was, I think, but we,
this is really the, um, archive
of our times times, not just our
national times, as you heard,
as Jennifer alluded to, but
also, the times of our
communities, geographically
around the country from coast to
coast, um, and culturally, and
believe me, um, local commercial
broadcasters have not been able
to preserve their archives.  It
has been too expensive for
them, it doesn't, you know, they
had to reuse those tapes or
couldn't spend the staff time,
given news cycles, and
especially now, given news
cycles, endless news cycles, so,
um, commercial  broadcasters
really have not, with a few
exceptions, been able to
preserve their  archives.  It
just wasn't their business plan.
So, it's more important than
ever that public media preserve
its archives, and it's also a
very critical part of our
mission that we make that
archive accessible.  It's been
part of the core mission of
public media from the very
beginning, that we make our work
available to everyone, no
matter where they are, no matter
what their means are, their
ability to pay, and especially,
in this universe now, where
almost everything is behind a
pay wall in media else where.
So, I'm very proud of the
progress we've been making
through the American Archive of
Public Broadcasting to put these
works up  online and make them
accessible.  Um, I want  to, as
we close, make a special thank
you again to the two co-heads of
the American Archive of Public
Broadcasting, Alan Gevinson in
the back for the Library of
Congress.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: And Karen Cariani
from WGBH, who shared the podium
with me.
(Applause.)
>> SPEAKER: Um, following Newt
's last clip, which is, I think
you'll find fun, there is a
reception in that room right
over there.  So, we thank you
again for joining us, and we
welcome you to the reception,
but first, the last word from
Newt.